you
[Music]
you're listening to radio smoothly
the untold
[Music]
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway only on
Sputnik radio there she was tucked away
in plain sight now in Israel or in Paris
but in New Hampshire Galan Maxwell is
finally under lock and key makes you
wonder how the FBI took so long to
locate her when her society friends in
Britain appear to have been in regular
touch with her mainly to assure
themselves that she wasn't going to put
Prince Andrew in deep doo-doo
and speaking of deep doo-doo don't
Trump's poll ratings are melting faster
than his makeup
there's even quite a book now been
opened on whether or not he'll even run
in November meanwhile Biden still hiding
the basement tapes still keep coming out
but no rave reviews and here in Britain
the Scottish nationalists vigilantes are
lining up across the border telling
English travelers by car to get the eff
out of Scotland believe it or not the
word um up in white suits with hoods yes
that's right
Scotland's KKK who are telling the
English to get lost even though the
follow is mainly being paid for by the
taxpayers in England and even more
pertinently aeroplanes are landing in
Edinburgh and Glasgow every 60 minutes
from abroad and not so much as a
temperature taken never mind being
turned away at the air frontier we'll be
talking of course about the coronavirus
and much much else this is a radio show
with pictures so fasten your seat belt
it's going to be an unusually bumpy
right
radio Sputnik we speak your language the
mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get free
[Music]
George Galloway
this is radio Sputnik this is London but
coming to you of course all over the
world thanks to the wonders of the
internet and Sputnik news calm
we're on FM in crystal clarity in the
Washington DC area
105.5 are the magic numbers there are
big audience by the way in Washington DC
including several members of Congress
imagine that they're supposed to be
boycotting our tea but they're watching
the mother of all talk shows we're on am
in the united states from burning city
to burning city and we'll be talking to
Robbie Martin first up about what's
happening down on the street in the
United States of America where's Biden
hiding and why are his basement tapes so
absolutely executable and what's
happening to Donald Trump his poll
ratings are now so dire that there's a
book been opened and quite sure odds
remarkably that he won't even run in
November personally I doubt that
myself but we'll be talking up first
here in my monologue of the seizure of
Gillian Maxwell the daughter of the late
thief robber baron Robert Maxwell and
seldom has an Apple fallen closer to the
tree than Gillian Maxwell
she was the old thief the old scoundrels
favorite child so much so that he named
his yacht off the back of which he fell
or was pushed the lady ghilane well lady
Gallade is currently behind bars
tasting porridge for the first time or
if she has a deal been done with the FBI
is it remotely plausible that they did
not know that she was hiding out in New
Hampshire when they were supposedly
scouring the world to interview her as a
suspect having been named
by literally dozens of young girls some
of them small children who claim that
Galan Maxwell and Jeffrey Epstein
sexually abused them attacked them raped
them that's right
capital our rape there ain't no consent
with a 14 year old girl ghilane and of
course Prince Andrew who famously cannot
sweat was last seen sweating because of
course
Gillian Maxwell was the air bridge
between the Jeffrey Epstein operation
and the British royal family Epstein
regarded Prince Andrew and described him
to witnesses as his Super Bowl icon
he was the jewel imagine what tawdry
crown that must have been the jewel in
Epstein's crown but there were many
other Krusty's in that crown the former
President of the United States Bill
Clinton for one they would be President
of the United States Hillary Clinton for
another the former Prime Minister of
Israel a Hood Barak and many many other
people are in this grisly tale of the
epstein operation now I watched as I
told you the Netflix series on Epstein
and it was very well done and it
demonstrated beyond any contradiction
the Lord's own immorality of the Epstein
circle and the black book in which many
big names are written have got something
to answer for I'm not saying that the
likes of Tony Blair and Peter Mandelson
were ever up to no good with young girls
on pedophile island or in the gigantic
townhouse in Manhattan which Epstein
miraculously purchased for $1 of the
owner of Victoria's Secret's quite a
secret
that one how that one dollar purchase
came about I'm not saying that that
those who are in the black book are
necessarily suspect of high crimes grave
felons
but they do have to explain what first
attracted them to the billionaire
Jeffrey Epstein they do have to explain
why they were so friendly with Epstein
and especially after after he had
already been convicted of sex offenses
against young girls and preeminent
amongst those is of course the Queen's
son Prince Andrew now we have a
remarkable standoff here Prince Andrew
claims that he's more than happy to
cooperate with the FBI the FBI keep
demanding that Prince Andrew cooperates
with them so I'm offering myself this
evening to bring the two parties
together and more than happy to broker a
series of interviews between the FBI and
His Royal Highness or his royal lowness
depending on how the interviews go
but somebody somebody somewhere must be
able to bring these two parties who say
they are desperately keen to meet and
talk and answer questions must be able
to bring them together so much for the
sex it's always interesting and in this
case it is utterly revolting repulsive
disgusting as low as it gets but I also
want to follow the money I want to know
where Epstein got all that money because
there is no discernible trace of how he
earned billions of dollars much of which
he left but most of which he spent on
lifestyle that can only be described as
plutocratic he was living as if he was
one of the richest men on the earth in
which case where did he get that money
whose money was it given max well it
said was given a four million dollar
helicopter as a present from Jeffrey
Epstein where did that money come from
where did the money come from for this
series of luxurious properties all over
the United States all over Europe and of
course infamously in the Caribbean where
the island will come to be the focus of
much attention when Gillian Maxwell goes
on trial now I'd be very surprised if
Gillian max were to commit suicide in
her cell probably not quite a surprise
that she would be but it's very very
important that the United States
authorities keep this woman alive
because she must see the inside of a
courtroom she must be made to answer the
allegations that still stand against her
and her late benefactor it is remarkable
because I have since the early 1980s
been at war with the Maxwell family
since the day probably before it that
her father Robert Maxwell punched me
full in the solar plexus in a BBC
greenroom just before going on
television for a live question time
broadcast in full view of Sir Robin day
and the other panelists on the show that
night
ah Mr Galway the PLO man he said prior
to thumping me in the stomach so hard
that I bent double and stood up straight
with tears running down my face I tabled
motions in the House of Commons asked
quest
in the House of Commons covered of
course by parliamentary privilege which
was the only way that the truth about
Robert Maxwell could be uttered in this
country without being crushed in illegal
action in a legal system that Maxwell
manipulated to the ultimate degree in
the end mr. Maxwell admittedly
posthumously had to buy me a car and a
wing on my house had to pay me a very
substantial sum in damages
having defamed me in retaliation for my
naming him in Parliament for multiple
criminal activities but more of that I'm
sure
later Donald Trump was a pal of Jeffrey
Epstein too just not as big a power as
Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton
appeared to have been or Peter Mandelson
for that matter
so the epstein affair is perhaps not an
existential danger to Donald Trump's
presidency but there are other
existential dangers as I said earlier in
my introduction the bookies are taking
bets now and offering short odds on
Trump being forced out of the race by
plummeting poll numbers the Basement
Tapes pitiful though they are for hidin
Biden are still coming out and Biden's
opinion poll rating is currently 50% to
Donald Trump's 36 even in Ohio Biden is
substantially ahead of Trump which would
mean an electoral college landslide now
you may say why why would Trump bow out
there appears still to be life in him
just not life as we know it well here's
the reason Donald Trump's going to badly
need a pardon and he can't pardon
himself if he is not to spend the rest
of his life behind bars or
kourt's trying to stay out of prison
he's going to need a president in place
that can pardon him for any crime or
misdemeanor that he may have committed
that would argue in favor of him making
way before November for vice president
pence who would then pardon
president Trump who could then go off to
golf til his heart's content and as long
as his bone spurs sustained him on the
18-hole walk around the course it's a
long shot for me I don't myself see it
but it's short odds now at the
bookmakers in the United States of
America we'll be discussing it with
Robbie Martin and Daniel Perrin pill in
the show today we'll be talking of
course about Venezuela whereas I I think
predicted last week in the short which
we showed you from our tea that the High
Court in London would legalize theft
without even wearing a mask they
legalized the theft of a billion dollars
worth of Venezuelan gold bullion handing
it to a man in the street on the
flimsiest or grounds that that man had
declared himself to be the president of
Venezuela it has not just been a theft
it's been a mother
it has muddled London's reputation as a
financial center and I have no
hesitation in saying to anyone who will
listen don't keep your money in London
if I were to win the National Lottery
the last place in the world I'd keep the
money is London because London's banks
are run by thieves th ie
ves thieves that's what you've done
High Court justices that's what you've
done Her Majesty's Government you've
destroyed one of the few assets that
this country
longer possesses that of being a safe
haven for people's money as safe as the
Bank of England used to be a thing when
I was young
turns out the Bank of England ain't safe
at all
and we'll be talking of course about the
Scottish nationalists car ghouls at the
border with their literally with their
their suits I don't know what you call
them nuclear biological chemical suits
and hoods and gloves and rubber over
their shoes who were arranged over the
border between Scotland and England
telling English travelers entering
Scotland how they knew there were
English travelers of course is a moot
point because I was one of them
perfectly legally going from one part of
my country to another part of my country
telling them to get the F out of
Scotland but to leave their money before
they turned back because of course of
the Scottish economy like the English
and Welsh economies would literally now
have collapsed if it were not for the
expenditure of the money's from the
Treasury in London from the taxpayer of
the entire UK which has through the
follow scheme saved the jobs of many
hundreds of thousands of people in
Scotland and many tens of thousands of
business businesses so tourists from
England
not wanted on voyage follow taxpayers
money leave it please at the border and
we'll pick it up this on the day that
the independence side of the great
debate in Scotland finally tipped in
favor of the Scottish nationalists 54%
say in a poll of 1,100
24 people admittedly that they will be
voting for independence if another
referendum comes along and only
therefore that's more or less reversal
of the figure that was achieved in 2014
the first time this matter was
considered in a referendum a referendum
which we were told was a
once-in-a-lifetime affair once in a
generation of there at least but which
turned out to not be accepted by those
who lost it who've been agitating for
another goal in the morning ever since
my position is clear
I think the breaking up of a small
island of english-speaking people would
be a very bad idea and it would be
particularly bad for the Scottish
working class which is the class about
which I care the most so we'll be
talking about all of these things and
the 72nd birthday of the National Health
Service and we've got a poll running
what birthday present should the NHS
receive a a PFI right off that's the
Private Finance Initiative which has
turned into a giant albatross around the
neck of the National Health Service
introduced first by the Conservatives
but multiplied many times over by that
most Scottish of all governments Tony
Blair Gordon Brown Robin Cook Donald
juror Alistair Darling and so on there
were more Scots in that government that
landed the NHS with this huge yoke
around its neck than any government in
all history so if being governed by
Scots is thought to be the be-all and
end-all the Blair Brown years would seem
to suggest that that ain't necessarily
all that matters so a a PFR write-off be
big pay rises for the NHS staff or see
free tuition fees for nurses you can
vote now on my Twitter feed at
George Galloway there's more much more
of this stay tuned
Radio Sputnik hello Peter express well
King what does he want
oh you want an ill-advised interview on
the BBC a cheese pizza extra immature
and of all bailouts no we don't take
taxpayers money yeah but we do take
contactors would you like a machine for
that mr. Prince
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends contributors and
callers everyone is welcome so first to
the United States Robbie Martin
filmmaker extraordinaire and of course
co-host of media roots radio joins us
now I hope from the United States Robbie
welcome back to the mother of all talk
shows let's start if we may with this
idea that has begun to circulate quite
powerfully in the United States that
Donald Trump won't even turn up in
November that you'll chuck it beforehand
in order to get a pardon for anything
he's done wrong from vice-president
pence who would then become the
Republican nominee where do you stand on
that well thanks for having me back
George I you know it's interesting you
ask that because I I think what I've
been seeing and I think that's what's
kind of going under the radar is that
it's not just Biden who appears to have
some form of serious cognitive decline I
would say based on that last Mount
Rushmore speech with Trump my main
takeaway from it other than him being
really desperate in his rhetoric is that
he appears to be suffering from some
kind of physical brain ailment or
cognitive decline that I mean if I was
his age I would think about just
throwing in the towel just in terms of
you know the the stress of the job and
whatever effect it might be having on
this potential physical condition he's
suffering from I wasn't even personally
factoring than the idea that he would
want to part him but that's that's
definitely an interesting component that
I mean could be very real who knows what
will continue to come out you know wait
you know Michael Cohen I mean what's
even his deal like what does he have to
say still I mean I don't trust the guy
but there's still a lot of loose ends in
terms of people that can you know pull
the rug out from under him in terms of
his criminal activities so I definitely
think that it's possible well it just
seems to me that the
the Democrats will be so vengeful
towards Donald Trump and with the
support of of course the fake news media
that Trump has been Lam busting in
virulent terms for four years that the
chances of Donald Trump leaving office
peacefully and then spending the next
few years in courts if not in jail that
would be a powerful incentive I think to
Donald Trump to bill hourly pence
becomes the standing president and
pardons Trump for any and all
allegations of criminal behavior I would
have thought that was quite an
interesting offer for President Trump
yeah I mean it could be potentially
depending on what I mean it would be
interesting to know what things Trump
may believe are looming over him
criminally well that's something I
haven't really considered but now that
you're mentioning it I mean there's got
to be there's got to be stuff out there
I mean even just the let's even just
talk about what you were bringing up
earlier the Epstein stuff I mean
Ghislaine Maxwell what's gonna come out
from her trial what's gonna come out
from Alan Dershowitz he just tweeted a
few hours ago that he hopes there's
videotapes that Epstein made because he
believes he'll be exonerated if they're
if they are so that could be a problem
is that on Robbie yeah in a safe place
yeah or he's or he has some kind of
really crazy fetish that he wants those
videos that come out look I have no idea
but the yeah it's it I think that could
be 10th to potentially be very bad for
Trump if that comes out because I think
based on his behavior
last time when Epstein was actually put
in jail before he committed suicide
Trump was awfully mom about that and you
would think for someone who is that
reviled Trump would have a lot of
horrible things to say about them but he
was awfully quiet so I think that that
signals that there is something in that
Ghislaine Maxwell arrests that will come
back to haunt him for sure so it could
even just be something like that
potentially were you shocked by Gillian
Maxwell's suicide next week yes I was
George I was I was very shocked do you
think she'll end up on trial or she cut
a deal with the feds I believe that she
will cut some kind of deal
I believe that she will and I don't know
what kind of deal that will be but if
she spills all the dirt it will unravel
this three decade four decade long you
know family lineage lineage of deep
state and conspiracies that will blow
everybody's mind I mean just uh just her
father and her sisters um that Whitney
Webb has been recently talking about is
uh is pretty revealing so yeah I mean I
I'm looking forward to seeing whatever
will come out but I do unfortunately
George I do think she will cut some kind
of plea deal her charges are actually
not even for underage child sex they're
for something else so that to me signals
that this might not be as good whereas
you know explosives everybody's hoping
it's going to be but I'm so hope it may
be that they they've spent the last year
or more when they were supposedly
looking for Gillian Maxwell
actually negotiating with Gillian
Maxwell on what she might plead to
absolutely yeah and and what was this
strange situation where she was staying
with some corporate CEO and some you
know rural mansion somewhere you know
who's that guy like it's just strange
how many connections she seems to have
two different oligarchs and people who
are like billionaires and
multimillionaires well yeah I think it's
very very likely she already cut some
kind of plea deal this will unravel the
lives and the reputations of so many
elites that it'll it'll be prevented in
some form whether that means ending down
on the street Robbie there's virtually
no coverage now of these demonstrations
and attacks on statues and so on but as
I understand they're all still going on
in significant numbers that's absolutely
right George I think what happened was
the media was really covering them
initially because of all the rioting and
the property destruction and they kind
of created this narrative where it was
like we will sort of back this you know
ideologically if the peat the protests
are very very safe and peaceful and I
think after that oddly they'd completely
stopped covering it for the most part
that's I think that's I mean I think
it's just it drove ratings to you know
cover things that look bad scary things
on fire and now that it's just all
peaceful protests it's not really a
ratings driver it's not really you know
gonna generate them advertising revenue
so I think from that perspective that's
probably why they aren't covering it but
yeah you're absolutely right it's
they're still going on there was just a
Columbus Christopher Columbus statue not
gonna in Baltimore barely got any
coverage so that is definitely true if
it seems like the right media are the
ones mostly covering it now because they
want to you know draw up hysteria
against the left so the corporate media
has kind of dropped that subject for the
time being it has never been a fourth of
July like this one has done well over a
hundred thousand people dead almost 30%
unemployment not safe to go out to to
imbecilic candidates fighting each other
for president and Kanye West and Kim
Kardashian enter DC is this serious are
they actually going to run for president
I mean I can't say but I can say that if
Kanye actually does run he will be able
to move the needle and capture a lot of
votes so if he's serious and if he
somehow gets I actually on the ballot
it's definitely going to have a real
impact on the election and there's no
denying that I mean so I don't know if
you know if any any other celebrities
will
to the race but it's pretty wild you
know and I don't know you know a lot of
people are sort of conspiracy now that
he's doing it because he's trying to
split the boat and give votes to Trump I
don't know if I believe that I don't his
relationship with Trump seems to be
strategic there are people who have sort
of unpacked that whole thing and made it
appear that Kanye is actually a huge
supporter of black lives matter and that
he's merely you know trying to get some
kind of criminal justice reform out of
his relationship with Trump I don't know
if I fully believe that but that's what
some people are saying right now so you
know there's different conspiracies
about it but in general I mean I think
he's gonna have a huge impact on the
election and it'll be weird because
Kanye you know was was talking about
things that were like pizza gate and
things like years ago so who knows what
his actual campaign platform is gonna be
but I'm looking forward to see how weird
it will be yeah he better watch how he
goes also because a lot of the things
he's been talking about are about the
very same people we were discussing
around the epstein affair exactly
exactly yeah and I mean Kanye is deep
deep in Hollywood you know so it would
be very interesting to see how that all
plays out but I kind of have a feeling
and I heard comedian Tim Dylan say this
and I think there's some truth to this
but I think Trump maybe even will want
to step down from the presidency because
he misses Hollywood even though all of
Hollywood hates him I feel that Trump
might want to somehow win those people
back over again and want to return there
because he's so many people hate him
right now I can't imagine that he enjoys
that just based on him you know his
personality so I don't that suggests a
thought I keep having so maybe maybe
it's kind of appropriate if Trump
returns to Hollywood and then Kanye
becomes president United States with Kim
Kardashian as the first lady remarkable
thought now finally Rabi and I'm
grateful for your time The Hiding Biden
he actually refused
used to do any debates in the
presidential election because it's
working for him so far he literally is
producing Basement Tapes and he's up 50%
in the polls
I think it's a very good question George
and I absolutely think that there we
will see in the coming months some kind
of push by the DNC or Biden's campaign
saying that a debate we can't do a
debate because of COBIT and because of
the lockdowns
or even potentially we can't allow
people to vote in the general election
so that's skipping ahead but I mean if
this if the Cova keeps spiking here in
the United States I think it's very very
likely we won't have any debates at all
and I can't even imagine
Biden debating trunk I mean he would get
absolutely trounced there's just no
chance that he would do well against
Trump so yeah I absolutely think that
they'll try to figure out a reason to
wiggle out of it and we're gonna
probably see announcements or signaling
towards that effect in the coming months
now neither of them is going to end up
on Mount Rushmore but it was quite
poignant I thought this weekend the not
just the unhinged speech of President
Trump who appeared to say that Operation
Desert Storm was a battle for in the
Vietnam War
which of course he dodged on account of
his bone spurs which miraculously cured
themselves when he took up golf but the
people who owned Montross Mount Rushmore
who owned it for whom it was sacred and
it was stolen from them when gold was
discovered in them thar hills
they were there as kind of ghosts in the
background one day yeah I mean Mount
Rushmore has a very odd and troubled
history I mean I was just reading that
you know for a monument that appears to
be in the tradition of sort of the
grandmas
you know architecture in the United
States tradition a lot of these stone
cutters who actually worked on Mount
Rushmore died from lung illnesses and
that's not even mentioning it the guy
who made it it was a crude Klux Klan
member there's so many weird things
about Mount Rushmore the original design
for two is they were gonna actually make
a full body you know if it took that
long to build it almost 25 years they
were gonna make a full body
representation of all these presidents
and imagine how garish and horrific that
would have looked carved into the side
of a mountain so I guess we're lucky
that all we got was an unfinished you
know for presidents busts outside of a
mountain but yeah it's it's really sad
to think that that was you know a sacred
Native American site the whole the whole
mountain side of it looks gorgeous
I mean the original you know rock
formations so yeah it is it is quite a
tragedy and I think that Trump is almost
kind of doing a preemptive strike and I
think that what what his speech really
Illustrated for me is that this campaign
has become desperate if he's if he's
essentially waging war against the left
social justice lawyer's black lives
matter anti-communist I mean it just
seems like a really desperate play going
into the election and I don't quite even
know if you know people in his team
agree with that strategy I would be
surprised if they did so I I'm confused
that he is appearing as desperate and I
don't know if it's actually gonna work
to his advantage I mean it will will
rile up his base but that's not enough
to you know necessarily really power him
to the election it's gonna be bite and
being so awful of a candidate it's
basically gonna be his ace in the hole I
think so maybe you're just counting on
that
Robbie Martin as always thanks for
joining us on the mother of all talk
shows much appreciated
now the polls running what birthday
present should the National Health
Service receive a a PFI right of 30
percent be big pay arises 40 percent see
free tuition fees for nurses thirty
percent you can vote now on my Twitter
feed at George Galloway let's squeeze
call Khurshid in leicester on the
lockdown
go ahead coach it hi mr. Geller how are
you doing I'm doing well I see you from
yourself
thank you I just wanted to ask you a
question I was wondering it's more like
an hypothesis but I was just wondering
what do you think about it
that is I mean there we know from from
before the Jeffrey Epstein
and Gillian Maxwell they were quite
close to Donald Trump
then you Donald Trump personally and
after Jeffrey Epstein arrest and death
in the prison last year he bit odd to me
that FBI because in the news today and
last week I saw that FBI was saying they
knew where Glenn Maxwell was hiding and
they've decided to arrest her now it
seems a bit odd to me that the timing of
her arrest because we are seeing that
the media or the most of the American
media I don't know ever the whole most
of the American media but a large chunk
American media the deep state is
plotting to get rid of Donald Tom is
there a correlation between delaying
Maxwell arrest and upcoming u.s.
presidential election there could of
course caution and Robbie was just
alluding to the somewhat of a mystery of
what happened to the relationship
between Epstein and Trump I mean they
were both in New York they were both
quote-unquote [ __ ] grabbing
misogynistic sexist and alleged rapists
in Donald Trump's case they had exactly
the same predatory attitudes towards
women we have the locker gate scandal
before Trump's election which revealed
how Trump viewed women including married
women as mere
fruits for him to pluck and it seems odd
that he wouldn't have been chummy with
Jeffrey Epstein who was involved in
exactly the same kind of predatory games
on the other hand
Epstein's relations with the democrats
are undoubtedly deeper and more people
are involved Epstein was not
conservative he was a part of that New
York Democratic milieu
there's no suggestion I think that Trump
was on the on the aeroplane that Trump
was on the island but Bill Clinton flew
on the airplane many many many times and
visited the island many many many times
and that included not just Bill Clinton
but Hillary Clinton also so it seems to
me that both parties are compromised by
their relationship to Jeffrey Epstein
Khurshid thanks for that first call now
every week I do a short for RT 24
minutes take a look this one's on
Afghanistan in the whole history of fake
news there's never been a more fake
piece of news than the New York Times
story about the Russians paying the
Taliban to kill American soldiers
[Music]
for a start the idea that the resistance
to foreign occupation in Afghanistan
needs paying well that's a bit out of
date the last people to pay for
resistance in Afghanistan was not Russia
about the United States of America
throughout the 1980s billions of dollars
in money and material weapons and
propaganda support was poured in by the
United States taxpayer into the fathers
or older brothers of the Taliban and the
purpose was not to kill American
soldiers but to kill Russian soldiers
thousands of whom they did kill you
might call it a bounty a dollar bounty
for every Russian head brought in but
the Afghans have been resisting foreign
occupation for centuries if not
millennia from Alexander the Great right
up to Donald Trump not the Great the
Afghan people have never accepted the
foreign occupation of their country you
can ask the histories of the British
army itself which was three times sent
packing by the Afghan resistance the
Afghan people will not accept foreign
soldiers on their land and never have
and they don't need anybody in Moscow to
pay them but the reality is this story
which was planted by sections of the
United States intelligence services in
the New York Times was then spread
across the whole world despite the fact
it was completely baseless and had no
evidence attached to it at all it was a
fact free story and is now completely
disputed by the intelligence chief of
the United States himself they said the
president was briefed on this fake news
story but in fact he was never briefed
because the intelligence services chiefs
themselves
knew that the story was completely
baseless the question that arises
therefore is why was this story planted
well we now know because the Democrats
in Congress have now tabled obstacles to
Donald Trump's plan to withdraw American
soldiers from the disaster of
Afghanistan just in case you've
forgotten we invaded Afghanistan Britain
and the United States and one or two
other European countries as long ago as
2001 or nineteen years ago the first
world war lasted four years the Second
World War lasted six years that's ten
years in total we've been in Afghanistan
almost twenty years almost twice as long
and have achieved absolutely nothing all
the blood that was spilled the blood of
our own soldiers the blood of American
soldiers but overwhelmingly of course
the blood of Afghan civilians has all
been shed entirely in vain the political
situation in Afghanistan today is
exactly what it was when all of this
began if the foreign forces would throw
from the country the Taliban would be
back in control before you could say
Jack Robinson and they didn't need
president Putin's rubles in order to
motivate them to do so and when the
Taliban are back in power all the
parents of all the soldiers that we lost
there will be asking what was all of
that for so just remember it wasn't the
Russians that were paying the Islamist
fanatics in Afghanistan it was the
Americans
have something to say do you disagree
with George then call us now and give us
your view don't forget to vote on my
Twitter feed what birthday present
should the National Health Service
receive my Twitter feed at George
Galloway
Sampson on Facebook says Sean that word
is really good
he's coming up shortly be interesting to
hear what he says max what can expect in
prison and what he thinks about the
circumstances around Epstein's death and
Connor also says can't wait Shawn at
word is always a great guest Maisy says
the British government is most likely
trafficking young men and women in this
country why are there no arrests and
Arthur says for Maxwell to leave a safe
home in France into the welcoming hands
of the FBI suggests a deal has been done
already the wheels of injustice have
moved into gear very interesting
conspiracy theory that one might have
some legs we'll talk to Shawn shortly
about that let's take some calls though
John is in buckshot in England let's
hear from him go ahead John hi George
good talks law nice undies usual thanks
mate what's enough fun Sondra it's
beating Maxwell fine yeah that is got to
come here cause it's been going on far
too long the victims need causer no
consensus get diplomatic immunity
okay understand ah I believe that can
only be used once has he already yep and
that's why he's not going in the u.s.
also I hate that the assets like that
going on Maxwell's got get the in frozen
the helicopter mansions get that sold
off on it put the money into the NHS but
helicopter for mowing pokin see if I
wore our lace used as any other
ambulance and I think my home said you
need to start putting a foot and to get
that's mine all 1382 each new powerful
John many thanks for it Sam is in
Cologne in Germany
let's talk to him Sam go ahead sir hello
my pleasure Galloway
Oh
by the grace of God I'm good thank you
go ahead thank you for having me
yes I'm want to talk about the fake
socialists like bernie sanders and
jeremy corbyn actually they disappointed
they're the left movement the socialists
and also the workers for example Jeremy
Corbyn has said into 2017 that he gonna
respect the result of referendum to
leave the European Union but
unfortunately that doesn't happen and
therefore they disappointed the the will
of the people and the same thing to be
to Bernie Sanders he said that I gonna
fight till the end and unfortunately he
betrayed also the people there the left
movement in the United States and he
called actually Joe Biden as a friend
who invited his friend by his friend Joe
Biden yeah his friend Joe Biden Joe
Biden he's a rapist actually he's a war
criminal and he said also that Bernie
Sanders had said the job that Joe Biden
has voted for the war on Iraq and he
called it he called her his his friend
and that's a paradox unfortunately and
these are unfortunately they gonna not
help the our movement I mean they're the
Left movement in the world so therefore
they have deeply disappointed us
unfortunately well thank you for that
Sam I've spoken many many times about
the disappointment of Jeremy Corbyn and
even Bernie Sanders though he's not
really my responsibility but Jeremy
Corbyn is a part of the British labor
movement and therefore my relationship
to his disappointment is more exact more
immediate
and if you want to know more about what
I've said about that you can look at the
speeches I've given I speak every
Tuesday evening on all platforms you can
look back the ones that we have held on
these very subjects let me give you the
number again if you're calling us from
the UK at so two or seven seven nine
eight two two five five that's or two or
seven seven nine eight two two five five
if you're calling us from the US it's
zero zero one seven five seven seven
four four four four eight zero or you
can tweet at George Galloway at RT UK
news and preferably both and you can
vote what birthday present should the
NHS receive writing off of its Private
Finance Initiative debt is up to on 32%
big pay rises still ahead but down one
on 39% and free tuition fees for nurses
down one also on 29% let's go to Georgie
in Spalding in on the NHS go ahead
Georgie I need you are you doing while
you're looking in fine fettle Thank You
Ottomans watching for Mia yeah good
stuff right now I've gone from the
purified because I'm thinking if you
write that off then we can restructure
the whole system which it really really
needs if you get people ages to their
level of incompetence being managers etc
and then we'll get the others like free
car parking among the rest of it that
will come into play as well sorry the
dog started barking oh [ __ ] man do you
work in the NHS Georgie yes I do when
I've had my translated test back because
I was rather poorly at the beginning of
last week and it's negative but I don't
trust it so I'm keeping in isolation for
seven days but you're absolutely right I
mean if I was voting on this my vote
goes through a because if you write off
the PFI you are freeing up a gigantic
sum of many hundreds of
or pounds that we are going in debt
charges on the PFA contracts and you can
use that to improve the service improve
the pay scrap the tuition fees and so on
if you want all PFI then you've got a
lot more money to play with
exactly and remember I mean I'm a nurse
myself but it's not just nurses it's the
whole of the workers and what we've got
is all these crafts that competes with
each other rather than associating with
each other and you'll get to example my
husband's the poor old quarters but
filled with all sorts home trust so just
paid minimum wage and they do not get
enhancements a weekend an anti-social
hours work other cost they do get the
enhancements just need sorting out and I
could say and I mean had the CEO of one
of the trust I used to work in he pulled
up the ward and spoke to one of the
deputy sisters he didn't size effect
would you do that correct myself they're
saying oh this bloke that died of code
read can you tell me about him and she
told the person to go forth and multiply
that's the many terms because basically
they want to put eulogize about this
chat that that meant this is no about
not enough PPE and then he died from it
so anyway that's my little men they call
a very very sad story that I must say
Linda on the email says why has the
government not included Portugal as an
air bridge I have just returned from two
weeks in Bordeaux she says the people
who are wearing masks social distancing
cautious and polite the only risk I had
was getting off the plane at Luton
Airport where I sat against the window
and watched people pushing to get off
and watch crowds of people with no masks
or social distancing the good people of
the Algarve will have their economy
ruined by a government that are clueless
seems poor reward for Portugal being the
oldest ally of Great Britain and all
that Jim says they have been likely
negotiating with ghilane for weeks
her insurance against being modock is
that she has some very interesting
pictures of some very powerful people
being entertained by Jeffry and others
the fact that she has now been
discovered and arrested indicates that
terms have been agreed but these are
likely for a much reduced sentence and
that the third party continues to hold
copies ensuring she keeps breathing the
question is are the FBI there to a
uphold the law or be to protect the rich
and powerful ah good question Michael is
in Clapton go ahead Michael
are they George just I would like to
know if you could clarify your stance on
the black lives matter position I am of
the view they're all lives matter
I mean conversation with various people
it appears on the rightest
for sign right there is the context in
which you're saying I mean
self-evidently all lives matter if you
are if you're a decent human being at
all but as I put it the other week
let me repeat it if your wife asks you
if you love are it's not the right time
to say I love everybody it would be true
to say that but it would not be the
right time to see it if your colleague
says to you my father just died it's not
the right time to say well everybody's
father dies and that also is true but
it's not the right time to see it when
the agony of black people is all over
your television screens because of the
disproportionate number of them being
killed and assailed by law enforcement
agencies in the United States
you got me Michael no no I don't George
because I think you're not using the
same sort of criteria to say that in the
two things you've just quoted it's it's
pretty indisputable that you know what
you were said but when it comes to
I'm burning my not we've all got one aim
is to crush rightfully wisely them well
I don't all have that one in no no but
fair-minded thinking people tell about
the court and the United States yes this
is quite this phenomenon the proximate
cause of all of this is the deep-seated
violent racism against black people in
the United States in particular but in
many other countries including our own
around the world now unless black lives
matter
then all lives don't matter so what's
the problem with both slogans at the
same time Michael oh I agree but so I
agree
great um to a certain dissent there in
conversations you have with people as
soon as you say all lives matter hmm
it's what I would say it's more
important than black lives matter
because it covers but lives that's the
problem Michael
it doesn't self-evidently we've talked
for weeks now about the number of people
of color who are killed by the security
forces in the United States of America
and we know of what happened in history
not just in the United States of America
but even here we know that much of the
wealth of this country in Glasgow in
Liverpool in Bristol in London was built
on the enslavement of black people so
black lives have not mattered in the
past so what's the problem with
embracing the slogan black lives matter
in fact all lives matter but if black
lives don't matter in practice then all
lives don't matter
thanks for the call Michael now
whichever platform you are watching us
on take a minute please to press the
share button tell your friends about the
mother of all talk shows on YouTube on
Twitter on Facebook but for the first
time if you use twitch yes we're on
another platform now 13 platforms we are
going out on this evening and one of
them is twitch Twi TCH search for motes
TV mo 80s TV we've got a new account
there you can join us on Twitch from
this very platform this evening so
whatever you do share share share a
Graham says I selected PFR right off
because managers who agree sensible
contracts at good prices are generally
fiscally competent wasn't an option and
Timur says big pay deal instead of
patronizing hand-clapping and always
says NHS staff have to pay for parking
at their own workplace you couldn't make
that up codger the height of kovetz or
many crime as they were fined a penalty
for exceeding their time because they
were working in the hospital in a public
health emergency this abhorrent parking
tax must be abolished for key workers in
general and the NHS in particular is
absolutely true and Yoda says you should
have given Maxwell a left and right
cross George finished with an uppercut
of a Glasgow kiss I wish I'd thought of
that
listen the first hour is almost by but
there's two more hours to come so stay
tuned to the mother of all talk shows
and first the news with Jamie Lowe
curious about our curricula have
something to say then call us now to
join the debate on the mother of all
nachos with George Galloway tune in
every Tuesday - loud and clear for a
regular segment called false prophets a
weekly look at Wall Street and corporate
capitalism where we talk about the big
economic issues of the week from the
point of view of working people the poor
and the us position in the global
economy join us this Tuesday and every
Tuesday with financial policy analyst
Daniel Sankey right here on radius but
think it's time to double down with Max
and Stacey yeah double down we're
talking markets finance business
economics to change blame just about
everything money related on Sputnik it's
called double down we're asking our dead
cats bouncing or have fundamentals
change that's this week and double down
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
[Music]
radio Sputnik news the rate of the
coronavirus deaths is almost entirely
preventable the UK government's former
chief scientific adviser has said today
Sir David King claimed that a further
27,000 excess deaths are likely between
now and next April under current
approaches to tackling the pandemic and
that this was unacceptable and immoral
Sir David who has been critical of the
easing of lockdown measures said we need
to look at the fastest route out of
covert 19 and the current one is not
right he said it looked as though
Downing streets policy was to maintain
the current level of about 3,000 new
infections per day across England his
comments come as pubs restaurants cafes
and Hair Salons reopened across England
on Saturday amid reports of some people
apparently flouting social distancing
guidelines as new regulations cleared
the path for bars to reopen on what was
widely dubbed as Super Saturday drinkers
packed beer gardens and outdoor areas
disorder in some parts of the country
force pubs to close early with police
making arrests after violent clashes
John Atherton national chairman of the
police Federation for England Wales
criticized the drunken behaviour of some
revelers and said that it was crystal
clear that they would not adhere to the
one meter plus rule as restrictions were
eased he tweeted finished my late shift
with apt hampt police Southampton City
late shift a busy shift we dealt with
anti-social behaviour naked men
possession of Class A drugs happy drunks
angry drunks fights more angry drunks
and was called a fascist Pig by somebody
that we tried to help health secretary
Matt Hancock in contrast said it was
nice to see people Anton about plans to
adequately fund the social care sector
need to be in place within a year the
head of NHS England has said the Simon
Stephens told the BBC the Cobra d-19
crisis has shown a very harsh spotlight
on the resilience of the care system
he added I would hope by the time we are
sitting down this time next year on the
73rd birthday of the NHS we have
actually as a country been able to
decisively answer the question of how we
are going to fund and provide
high-quality social care from
parents generation if you take back the
history coming out of the Second World
War the country at that point was on
austerity we have rationing for bread
and potatoes the founders of NHS did not
use that as a moment to hesitate they
said let one of the legacies of the war
be the creation of the NHS there has
been a world-record rise in coronavirus
cases over a 24-hour period the World
Health Organization has said the new
record is two hundred and twelve
thousand three hundred and twenty-six
with the biggest rise in infections
coming in the u.s. Brazil and India the
previous w-h-o record for new cases was
one hundred and eighty nine thousand and
seventy seven on the 28th of June in
English there were further 53 thousand
two hundred and thirteen cases reported
in the latest 24-hour period ahead of
Brazil and India across Europe the
figure rose by nineteen thousand six
hundred and ninety four but as the
United States marked a somber fourth of
July with many people from fine for
their homes over coronavirus President
Donald Trump in his speech on the White
House lawn made the astonishing claim
the 99% of coronavirus cases in America
are totally harmless
the president's assertion was without
evidence and was his latest attempt to
minimize the threat of the virus as it
ravages the United States in another
sign of the growing rift between the
West and China Britain is poised to end
the use of far away technology in its 5g
network over security concerns Boris
Johnson is set for a major policy change
after the UK intelligence agency GCHQ is
believed to have reassessed the risks
posed by the Chinese company the Prime
Minister decided in January to allow
quar way to pay a limited role in the
UK's 5g network as he defied security
concerns particularly from the US about
the firm and finally the u.s. rap star
Kanye West has announced in a tweet that
he is running for US president and he's
already won the backing of billionaire
Elon Musk West posted a message to his
twenty nine point four million Twitter
followers suggesting he was entering the
2020 race Tesla chief executive must for
bonded to West's tweets saying you have
my full support if Kanye West does run
he won't be stuck for funding apart from
his own money and what musk may offer
him his wife Kim Kardashian last week
saw the stake in her cosmetics company
for 200 million dollars that's the
latest here on Sputnik I'm Jamie Lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio Sputnik
the untold
[Music]
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway only on
Sputnik radio you're watching the mother
of all talk shows and the best guests
are ours and your parent Bell is not
just one of the United States as young
and up-and-coming journalists of the
first rank
she's also a specialist on Venezuela
having been there what they're made
films from there to my certain knowledge
indeed I have interviewed her before
about Venezuela but I wanted to do so
again because this is the week of course
in which the Bank of England following
the policy of the British government won
their case in the High Court in London
and stole a billion dollars worth of
gold from Venezuela now as I said
earlier this is not just theft it's the
model of London's reputation as a
financial centre no country with any
sense would any longer keep its
sovereign wealth banked in London
because all you need to do is fall out
with the British government they
recognize your opposition unilaterally
as the legitimate government and they
steal your country's sovereign wealth
and they hand it to the leader of the
opposition although in the case of one
guardo he isn't even the leader of the
Opposition in Venezuela has been deposed
by the opposition in Venezuela and of
course of Venezuela I wanted this
billion dollars to go not to president
maduro's back pocket but to the United
Nations Development Program to fund
Venezuela's fight against the corona
virus remember that Venezuela has a
border with Brazil where the pandemic is
rampant one of the worst I think the
second worst affected country in the
world and a border with column
which ditto is ravaged by the disease
the Venezuela has miraculously and
through terrific social organization
kept the number of fatalities from the
corona virus as one of the lowest in the
world and it wants to keep it that way
so what news from Venezuela in the week
of this London High Court decision
there's nobody better to ask than Anya
Perrin pill Anya welcome back to the
mother of all talk shows
first of all we'll have commas are a big
surprise in Venezuela that the British
courts are found for the British
government rather than the government of
Venezuela no George I don't think anyone
with knowledge of the functions of the
former British Empire and now how the UK
has continued to act as an extension of
the US Empire I don't think anyone is
surprised that the courts have gone in
the favor of the Bank of England and and
the wealthy elites of the British as
opposed to ruling on the side of the
Venezuelans it's a theme we've seen in
the United States as well George
something I've covered closely here is
the battle over citko which is
Venezuela's largest and most expensive
highest valued international asset we're
talking about billions of dollars here
worth in this refinery Citgo for people
in the United States is a gas station
that supplies about 4% of petroleum to
cars in the United States oil for for
vehicles here and many people didn't
realize that it's actually owned or was
owned by ped of ASA the state-run oil
company in Venezuela up until last year
up until the initiation of the Trump
administration's coup Venezuela would
ship its crew to the United States it
was refined in these facilities owned by
sit go here and then pumped out by
Americans paying at the pump
ever since sanctions restricted
Venezuela's ability to export its crew
to the United States the wydo officials
I've lost
Anya I'm so sorry about that we'll get
back to her don't worry
what birthday present should the NHS
receive a a PFE PFI write-off be a big
pay rise see free tuition fees for
nurses and Timor says watching motes
tonight be enlightened with a
knowledgeable lineup and the man himself
George Galloway tackling the subjects
that are the hot topics of conversation
and interest to us all including Gillian
Maxwell and Yoda said no I've done that
one he'll door says Gallade Maxwell will
die of corvid 19 and on Facebook Charlie
says we're simply a captive audience for
the theatre of world politics we have no
control or say of any kind but they have
to delude us into thinking that we do
and tom says Maxwell is the most
protected person on the planet and yes
she's already done a deal with the
authorities Stephen says they won't
Trump out more than anything else on
this planet they will cause any event to
try and destroy him they can't
assassinate him because that would be
way too obvious and Charlie says any
conservative politician is guilty of a
multitude of crimes
it's whether they're found out or not
and brian says getting the popcorn out
and on youtube aussie says trump waddles
from his golf cart to the ball never
walked 18 holes in his life well it does
have bad ankles which means of course
that he had to miss the war
unfortunately in Vietnam we back in
touch with Anya Anya you are explaining
how this gas station chain in the United
States most people didn't even know it
zoned by the Venezuelan government
through its state holding in the oil
company petrov esse but then there as
well i couldn't export its oil to the
united states what happened next what I
have covered very closely and what's
just been stunning to witness George is
how the figures representing Juan Y
dough in the United States
Carlos Vecchio his ambassador to the
United States the man who served until
just last month as his attorney general
Jose Ignacio Hernandez he and and
Vecchio both really are just figures who
work on behalf of oil companies Vecchio
himself was a lawyer a high-level lawyer
representing Exxon Mobil in Venezuela
and its fight against the Venezuelan
government until it was kicked out of
the country in 2007 and Jose Ignacio
Hernandez is very important someone that
we should all know about because we
don't hear about him as much as other
figures but he actually built the legal
framework and assisted corporations in
the United States fighting for
essentially their right to liquidate
Citgo again this is Venezuela's largest
international asset it's its crown jewel
on the world stage and because it is now
under the management of these figures it
stands to be liquidated at the order of
the court in order to pay back multiple
international corporations again crystal
X is this Canadian mining company I
mentioned there's another one a glass
company based in the United States
oh I European group and what these
companies have done is sued Venezuela's
government court we've now been awarded
multibillion-dollar settlements and so
in order to get paid these companies are
saying all right you're the judge is
gonna say liquidate sit go sell it
essentially to other oil companies
meaning Exxon the former employer of his
Guido's ambassador to the United States
anyone can buy up the refinery the gas
station and then
money will go not into the hands of the
Venezuelan people but back into these
multinational corporations which are
assuming the Venezuelan government and
Jose Ignacio Hernandez Juan Guido's
Attorney General it's someone who before
he was appointed Attorney General by
Guido in the National Assembly he was a
Venezuelan lawyer working in the United
States at Harvard University and believe
it or not he was actually paid by
multiple oil companies and this is a
story that I'm coming out with this week
to illuminate this a bit more but I've
also published already some
investigations on the grades and about
this these multinational corporations
suing the Venezuelan government actually
paid Jose Ignacio Hernandez for legal
testimony he was an expert witness in
these cases in order to prove that
crystal acts or these these vultures
that are essentially vying for a piece
of Venezuela as internationally stored
wealth they called on him paid him for
his testimony in the courts to support
their legal arguments against the
Venezuelan government and then when he
took over as Guido's Attorney General he
actually assisted by making decisions
which helped prove the legal argument
basically that Citgo even though it was
a private u.s. corporation because it
was owned by Penev ASA was something
that the the courts here could
legitimately liquidate and and and turn
over to these corporations these people
that represent the Guido administration
in the United States they don't
represent any people in Venezuela they
only represent multinational
corporations the oil companies that are
actually succeeding while they're not
succeeding in Caracas and I don't think
many of them ever thought that they
would George anyone who know something
about Venezuela has been there and knows
that these people didn't have a chance
at seizing power in Caracas or they have
succeeded with this coup is in setting
the stage with their their declaration
of representing Venezuela they now have
succeeded in stealing billions of
dollars of this country's wealth it's
what you're seeing in the UK it's what
you're seeing in the United States
Caracas doesn't matter all that matters
are the bank accounts in New York in
London
they have that money they're paying
themselves with that money
they're paying out foreign corporations
with that money and so this just really
demonstrates George I think the need for
countries like Venezuela to look for a
system beyond the u.s. program you mean
the more you talked Anya the more I was
a GOG at the idea that a country like
Venezuela should have so much of its
capital seasonal buy by the United
States or Great Britain for that matter
no global South country should ever
again leave a dollar or a penny in
either your country or mine this has
been a long time coming
again as you spoke I realize that this
is exactly the playbook that they used
against Iraq before they invaded and
occupied it they bled it white seized
its assets paid themselves and paid the
corporations with Iraq's money you would
have thought that people would have
learned the lesson from that period I
hope they learn it now don't you
absolutely George I think that is the
lesson to come from Venezuela you can
have your country under control you can
defeat these forces at home the way
Venezuela has they've defeated this coup
on multiple occasions actual military
threats made against the country but no
matter how strong or capable of
surviving the political project was in
Venezuela the fact that wealth was
stored in the United States and Europe
just put them in a situation where I
again nobody's surprised that these
courts rule in favor of the capitalists
and the in the in the colonial hubs
because that's what they're designed to
do but I do have hope George because
unlike the situation the global
situation and the lead up to the war on
Iraq
now we're decades out of the collapse of
the Soviet Union the United States is
not the sole reigning power
in the world anymore in fact something
that gave me hope was last year I went
to Venezuela to attend the meeting of
the foreign ministers and some heads of
state of the non-aligned movement which
is the largest group of countries in the
United Nations 120 member states
essentially everyone other than the
United States Canada and European
nations in Africa Asia the parts of the
world that the Economist never includes
in its maps parts of the world that the
Economist never includes in its maps are
represented by this block the
non-aligned movement and they met to
discuss this very issue I was in the
room when foreign minister Javad Zarif
from Venezuela from Iran I'm sorry
pled with his colleague saying don't
call these measures that are placed on
our country's sanctions we're not being
punished for anything this is financial
terrorism he held up his phone and he
said Google the definition of terrorism
and you'll understand that this is
exactly what the United States and its
allies are doing to Iran Venezuela North
Korea many of the countries in the room
all are faced with this war and the
Deputy Foreign Minister of Russia Sergei
Ryabkov was actually present for that
meeting and I had the opportunity to
interview him and he couldn't understand
this is the primary focus is building a
financial system not based in London not
based in New York or Paris but based on
mutual cooperation and an alternative to
the European US dominated system that
we've faced now for over 100 years I
mean this is the only way that these
countries are going to be able to
develop and survive in a sovereign and
independent way is one they really can
truly operate outside of this system and
that's what Russia is working towards
that's what China is working towards now
and I think these countries are in a
better position to to make those moves
now than they were say in 2001
during the lead-up to the war in Iraq
again in the United States its
objectives were defeated even in Syria
so it's been a slow slow defeat with a
lot of pain and a lot of suffering the
impact of these sanctions cannot be
overstated people are suffering people
are dying as a result of this economic
war but I do still think there is hope
because the rest of the world is giving
up on really cooperating with or seeing
the United States especially as an
honest partner or somewhere where you
can even store your money very positive
note to end on thank you very much on
your parent Bell of the grave zone look
forward to your piece this coming week
on the venezuelan situation thanks for
joining us on awkward is our next guest
on Epstein and ghilane Maxwell but let's
take a quick break first radio Sputnik
[Music]
tune in every Wednesday - loud and clear
with Brian Becker and John Kiriakou for
a regular segment called beyond nuclear
where Brian and John discuss nuclear
issues including weapons energy waste in
the future of nuclear technology in the
United States with Kevin Kamps the
radioactive waste watchdog and the
organization beyond nuclear listen on
Wednesdays right here on radio slepping
[Music]
want to talk get in touch with us at
radio at Sputnik news.com
but first that was the week that was I
looked back at the seven days in history
which shaped our world for good and
Allah was on this very day 72 years ago
that one of the greatest political and
social creations came into being it was
the National Health Service which the
then Health Minister an Aaron Bevin
launched at the Park Hospital in
Manchester on July the 5th 1948 it was
based on three principles which are as
true and necessary today as they were
then firstly that the services helped
everyone secondly that health care was
free at the point of need and finally
that care would be provided based on
need rather than ability to pay we've
seen how vital our NHS is during the
comic ovid crisis and has been every day
since it was launched 72 years ago but
we simply must take it wholly back into
public hands
we need the nationalization of the
National Health Service back to what it
was supposed to be
it was also today in 1811 of that seven
Venezuelan Declaration of Independence
was declared when seven provinces in
Venezuela declared themselves
independent of Spain and also on this
day in 1989 that the former White House
aide Oliver North escaped jail for his
part in the iran-contra affair I was
shocked when he escaped Jill absolutely
shocked the decorated Vietnam veteran
was convicted of 3 out of 12 charges
relating to illegal United States
support for the Contra rebels in
Nicaragua in the mid-1980s
throat-cutting specialists they were
they used to cut people's throats and
then hang their tongues out as Thais and
I have seen it
he received instead of jail a three-year
suspend
prison sentence and two years on
probation you couldn't make it up on
July 10th one of the great meetings in
musical history took place when
sixteen-year-old
John Lennon and Paul McCartney a year
younger met with Lennon's group The
Quarrymen and performed at a church fete
on the same day in 2000 Prime Minister
Tony Blair's eldest son Ewan was
arrested for being drunk and incapable
after police found the 16 year old lying
on the ground in Leicester Square after
celebrating the end of his GCSE exams
with his friends as you do he was taken
to Charing Cross police station gave a
false name an old address and a date of
birth that suggested he was 18 the legal
age for drinking so the Apple didn't
fall far from the tree there either on
July 7th in 1947 one of the world's
great conspiracy theories or cover-ups
was launched when aliens and their
spacecraft were discovered or not
Roswell in New Mexico it has been
debunked more times than even Donald
Trump's claims but there are still
believers out there although I don't
want them to contact me and in 1969 an
inquest hurt that former Rolling Stones
guitarist Brian Jones drowned after
taking a cocktail of drink and drugs and
on the same day in 2005 and it's one I
remember well because I was a member of
parliament there a series of bomb
attacks on London's transport network
killed more than 30 people and injured
about 700 others three explosions on the
underground left 35 dead and two died in
a blast on a double-decker bus the first
three bombs went off just outside
Liverpool Street and edge were road
stations and on another travelling
between Kings Cross and Russell Square I
spoke in Parliament that afternoon in
what became quite heated exchange it's
worth looking at 7-7 to
thousand and five on July 8th in 1099
and what was the first crusade 15,000
starving Christian soldiers marched in
religious procession around Jerusalem as
its Muslim defenders looked on and in
1965 Ronald Biggs a member of the gang
who carried out the Great Train Robbery
in 1963 escaped from one swath prison he
got out by scaling a 30-foot wall with
three other prisoners pigs was free for
nearly 40 years
before he returned voluntarily to
Britain from Brazil and was imprisoned
on July 10th in 1940 as Britain was
still digesting the miraculous Dunkirk
evacuation the Battle of Britain began
as the German Luftwaffe mounted a series
of attacks on shipping convoys of the
southeast coast of England although
heavily outnumbered the British pilots
put up a fierce fight and succeeded in
driving of the attackers Prime Minister
Winston Churchill memorably put it this
way
never in the field of human conflict was
so much owed by so many to so few and in
1995 7,000 Bosnian Muslim men were
massacred
when Bosnian Serbs overrun the United
Nations safe haven of Schreber Anita and
United Nations troops stood by and
allowed it and to end on a happier note
it was on July 11th 1969 just days
before the Apollo 11 landed on the moon
David Bowie released Space Oddity and
that was the week that was in our
history let's go to Richard in Concord
on Jesse Ventura I hope it's good news
Richard go ahead yeah I've got some
exciting news for you George I hope
you're doing well
Thanks so there's so there's a
significant chance now that with enough
pressure the Green Party will
the right thing and nominate governor
Jesse Ventura popular opinion has been
shifting as many in the party now are
pushing to contest the results of the
primary due to issues with the process
and to put that into context complaints
have been filed within the party as well
as with the Federal Elections Commission
that are in review and I won't get into
all the details because there's many but
the best example that I have is that
there have been states that have chose
to only put Howie Hawkins on their
primary ballot and even then he almost
lost to none of the above so there's
lots of pressure within the party for a
different nominee and I think the people
are hungry for a third party to be
viable at this point for the left wing
here in the country well we had Howie
Hawkins on the show he didn't cut much
of a - and certainly nothing like the -
that would be cut by Governor Jesse
Ventura who is extremely well known in
the country both from his past as as a
military figure as a former Navy SEAL as
a veteran of of the Vietnam War the one
that Donald Trump dodged he is of course
the governor of Minnesota who defeated
the Republicans and the Democrats in a
tightly 4-3 party race for governor of
the state he was also the mayor of
Minneapolis dito when he defeated both
of these parties he's a significant
figure a charismatic figure and if the
Green Party put him up as their
candidate I'll tell you something he's
in with a show of winning because you
mentioned none of the above if there was
a none of the above option available
between Joe Biden and Donald Trump
none of the above would win yeah we
wouldn't have a president if that was
enough you know on the presidential
ballot exactly exactly so so this
possibility
of the green party picking governor
Jesse Ventura when will we know for sure
Richard well the Green Party National
Convention is next weekend it is July 11
at noon Eastern Time
is when it starts and every candidate
who has enough delegates will be
eligible to speak and governor Ventura
is one of those candidates so we'll know
within the next week whether the Green
Party has chosen to help with the
progressive movement or to stick with
the a done of a candidate as both of us
seem to agree upon well you know I
literally will pray for that outcome and
I think that governor Ventura would
immediately catapult the Green Party
into every headline into every argument
every debate the social media would go
wild with the with a candidate of his
stature and his presence his political
heft entering the race against these two
these two sclerotic old melting men
Donald Trump and Joe Biden it would be a
stunning turn of events yet there's more
that we can do than just pray George if
folks want to help out they should go to
draft Jesse calm and sign up for our
newsletter to get volunteer
opportunities and also sign our petition
at change.org slash Ventura 2020 we need
all the popular support we can get to
show the Green Party that this is an
opportunity they cannot miss out on
bang-on thanks for that Richard that's
very good news indeed let's go to line
two
where Vinnie is in East London on the
Glenn Maxwell story
go ahead Vinnie I like how you did my
good good tell me what do you think I'm
just thinking that you know there's
nobody in the world yes yeah I don't
know where they are you wouldn't have
thought so no I don't know in the wrong
country no exactly
but they know where everybody else is
but I'm just I'm just worried about
what's going to happen because they're
you know I mean what she knows some
people don't look after no sure there's
only two options are three either she
goes into court and sings like like a
canary in which case the whole world
will know just how horrific this whole
epstein operation was and who mounted it
the second option is that she commits
suicide before the trial or is mothered
and the third option is that she cuts a
deal with the FBI which conceals the
truth about the case and grants her a
very limited time in prison I like your
third option which was she cut - do I
think she's cut she had cut the bill
beforehand because she would not be
staying in America you know VI and
anybody can pounce on you she would have
gone straight away to a country that has
no extradition like France why did she
not either
that means you feel safe well maybe she
wasn't confident she could get out the
country I don't know if you've got many
cars boats I mean you know anybody
lovely told me she chose you but your
skepticism when you okay for me now it's
your turn to be the prime minister thank
god bless you thank you so much for that
the pool is going well PFI write-off is
now on 35% up three big pay rises 38%
down one and free tuition fees for
nurses 27% down - that's the poll on
what your favorite birthday present for
the National Health Service on its
72nd birthday would be let's go to tests
in Pembrokeshire in wills on the US
elections go ahead yes
uh hi George wouldn't that be something
you as Prime Minister one day that's
right okay I've been watching the news
Kanye running for president with the
backing of Elon Musk right we've had
months and months and months of
selection process and letting him down
and debates and lesson about and hassle
hassle and then all of a sudden so I'm
like super rich guy comes in and says
hey I want to be President and another
super-rich guy goes yeah okay I'll back
you up
and and that seems like it might be a
goer one could almost say you can buy
your wages well that is truth
self-evident the the last presidential
election in 2016
each candidate spent 1 billion dollars
so if you're not rich or have the
backing of the filthy rich you might as
well not bother turning up and so Kanye
West might be richer than the other two
I suspect he is if you include his his
wife sir wealth and Elon Musk is also a
very wealthy men man so I think this is
the age of the independent if the two
mainstream parties can't come up with
better than Kirsten and Boris Johnson
here
Donald Trump and Joe Biden there well
what's not to love about other third
forces 456 forces coming on to the field
so I think I think it's quite an
interesting development well I do too
but it's from what I understand isn't it
money that's holding up Jesse Ventura
from running didn't he say that that was
one of the the issues he had was that he
would lose employment and he to have
been taken care of and he's now off and
running for the Green Party nomination
the reason that's important is the Green
Party's already guaranteed
spot-on every ballot in every state
whereas kanye west will have to go some
to get on the ballot in every state but
yeah as Robbie Martin said earlier you
know most people's initial reaction a to
Kanye West's entry into the race was to
laugh it certainly was my first reaction
but the more you think about it this is
a guy with a total a gigantic footprint
in the United States and and all the
money that's necessary to fight a proper
campaign well a blast I hope they both
go ahead I hope they bring some interest
into the election because otherwise
there's going to be just a complete
nightmare test thanks very much for that
Edmond says the virus never was in
Scotland the figures were lies not one
person tested died of kovat that's
Edmund in Carstairs Keith says at last
someone questioning where all the money
came from he's talking about the money
that's kept the Scottish economy afloat
most of which of course of necessity
came from England will says whoever wins
America will crumble and Rick says they
opened the pubs and people went crazy
and didn't social distance instead were
drunk and having mass gatherings the
government says it's guided by science
that's a laugh they're guided by the
economy and taxes and Constance says
there's nothing wrong with Trump
mentally he's just a money-grubbing
crass half-educated businessman type not
a bad description let's take a quick
break on that
radio Sputnik tune in every Wednesday -
loud and clear with Brian Becker and
John Kiriakou for a regular segment
called beyond nuclear where Brian and
John discussed nuclear issues including
weapons energy waste and the future of
nuclear technology in the United States
with Kevin Kamps
the radioactive waste watchdog and the
organization beyond nuclear listen on
Wednesdays right here on radio slurping
[Music]
[Applause]
want to talk get in touch with us at
radio at Sputnik news calm
we are talking 24 hours a day seven days
a week you are listening out of the
endless information space radio Sputnik
telling the untold radio Sputnik we
speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm I'm
speaking
[Music]
radio Sputnik
George Galloway and the murder of old
talk shells join us at the college of
knowledge where there are no tuition
fees
well I mean that sounded like Joe Biden
how could we tell if it was our own
blithering idiot or him what birthday
present should the NHS receive a a PFR
write-off 35 percent be a big pay rises
38 percent see free tuition fees for
nurses you got 10 minutes left to vote
on that almost a thousand of you have
already on my Twitter feed at George
Galloway now Sean at word author speaker
broadcaster extraordinaire makes a
welcome return to the mother of all talk
shows because he's been the man in front
on the whole Epstein Gillen Maxwell case
perfect time for Sean to return to the
show Sean app would thank you for
joining us what was your first reaction
when you heard about Gillian Maxwell's
suicide next week apparently she's gonna
go down with the virus next week and be
critical and expire so I interviewed
Maria farmer before she got the gag
order she was a victim who was assaulted
by both Maxwell and Epstein and seen
Maria and the other victims like
Virginia on the filthy-rich recently
whereby they were in court the judge
talked and finally like they were human
beings like they weren't child
prostitute and criminal criminals and
all this stuff just to see and hear the
utter joy in the victims now finally
after decades of the bravery and
campaigning to get this far to bring the
chief procurer I'm not just a procure
remind you a participant in the assault
of children who'd been trafficked sexual
assaults on them to get this woman and
finally to justice it's just just a huge
congratulations to the victims that's
what I say yes I mean this is an
important point that you've just made
there it would be seen
is enough if the allegation was that she
was the one
touring the playgrounds to procure the
children for the Beast epstein but
actually a very significant number of
these children allege that Maxwell also
had sex with them therefore also raped
them this is something that doesn't seem
to have so far cost how the friendship
of many in high society in both the US
and the UK especially Prince Andrew now
Virginia said that there was an orgy on
the island and Prince Andrew
participated Maxwell participated there
were underage girls there who'd been
procured from Eastern Europe and they
were joking that they were the easiest
girls to abuse because they didn't speak
any English and for Prince Andrew now to
be playing the victim card he's saying
that he's not being treated like any
normal person would in the US justice
system
prosecutors are leaking information
about the case because he's such a big
name and they're making headlines off
him well yes Prince Andrews right in one
regard he's not being treated like
anyone else in the world would be
treated as anyone else it was a
conspirator in the biggest child sex
trafficking pyramid scheme in US history
what we SWAT team raided would be stuck
in a jail cell right now it's in green
bologna sandwiches with cockroaches
crawling all over at night and prison
gangs trying to stab them to death for
being a sex offender warmers are all
about Shawn it has to be an operation to
gather compromise on powerful rich and
important people because that's the only
explanation for the huge flows of money
at the disposal of Epstein the
extraordinary interventions from the top
before his first trial
and conviction and the extent to which
powerful people remained friends with
them even after he had been convicted am
i right right for this interview I just
interviewed ex CIA officer Robert Steele
and he said this is a massive
Intelligence Agency operation still
ongoing with units all across the
country and the world and that the boss
of ghilane and Epstein in this case was
Leslie Wexner of the limited and I was
looking at the transactions between
Epstein and waxen how Epstein got his
wealth and basically it was passed the
parcel on all these property deals
valuations were miraculously just
increased and their money was
transferred from one city oversaw Wexler
is the one now who should be being
looked at not just for fraud and money
laundering but Maria farmer said she was
assaulted at a wax the property and
watched this bodyguard
ooh bodyguards Hollywood celebrities
right now while say his name was pacing
and threatening to murder her and
telling us she was never gonna get out
of her and she was so fearful for her
life the only way she got out was
because she managed to get a dad to come
and rescue her from the situation so as
this goes up the ladder the next rung on
the ladder is Wexler but mainstream
media is purporting that
Epstein and Maxwell are at the head of
the conspiracy they won't cross that
line to show what's above them the
Intelligence Agency apparatus the
Clinton crime family lists the Clintons
that are untouchable in this it's Prince
Andrew that's untouchable in this but in
the eyes of public opinion Andrew is
ruined and the Clintons should be
exposed next well of course president
Trump's in control for now at least he's
in office if not in control he's in
charge of the Justice Department his he
always wanted to lock her up why doesn't
the
Department now proceeded to lock up the
clintons because the Clinton Bush crime
families have so many people embedded in
all of the federal agencies and have so
much power still it's a line that won't
be crossed you sure yeah everybody have
spokes you on this case there's not
field that the Clintons will be ever be
held accountable or Prince Andrew will
see a day in jail on the latter point
I'm perfectly sure you're right about
that
now if there was if we and we both
agreed the only explanation for the
things I adumbrated would be that this
was much more than a sex case it's a
disgusting sex case but it's much more
than that has to be the amount of money
the interventions to save them and the
ongoing friendships even after
conviction all point to blackmail all
point to compromise in which case where
is that where are the pictures
where are the videos Sean well the
victims have stated that they've seen
control rooms they've seen where the
cameras were hidden they know about the
tapes one of the Florida cops
Joseph rockery who mysteriously died in
his early 50s it was perfectly healthy
he transferred a lot of that material to
his superiors who he didn't trust I was
told that by another guy it was in the
Florida cops over the John Mark Duggan
who ended up fleeing over to Russia
now Doggett is claiming that that
information when was passed to the
higher-ups not just to the CIA and
corrupt parts of the FBI but all sorts
mi5 and mi6
because there was stuff in there that
compromised Andrew well and also
presumably the Israeli Secret Service's
because there was there one of the most
frequent visitors to Epstein's townhouse
in Manhattan was the former Israeli
prime minister and would bother
well Robert Steele
the Maxwell family Mossad
through-and-through Maxwell was bringing
Epstein into that fold because they
needed a man to capture men to
compromise men that was the rationale
now I'm about to run a poll Sean will
Gillian Maxwell face a trial I know
there'll be a plea deal of B there'll be
a presidential pardon or C that she will
be jailed the only good taste precluded
us adding another option namely that she
will somehow perish from covet 19 or
hanging herself with paper sheets in an
in a cell that isn't filmed and over
which there is no God which of those
four options would you settle on
I think Wexler and the Clintons will be
instrumental in having her whacked works
this tax attorney was taken out mob
style and the police accidentally
released the report showing all of
Wexler ties to organized crime
so if Wexler was their immediate boss
they were mid-level managers
responsibility is gonna fall on him like
it does in the Mafia like you saw in
Goodfellas your friends end up killing
you now if she doesn't end up dead
there's no way it's gonna end up in a
trial when Kenneth leg got arrested I
said to my friends there's no way this
is going to end up in a truck as a trial
certain names are mentioned government
agencies have to take action so if she
doesn't get killed
it's gonna end up in a plea bargain and
then a plea bargain certain measures and
agreements may be made to protect the
higher end of the Intelligence Agency
apparatus a plea bargain still sends out
to prison for many years effect which
our Father escaped by jumping off the
back of his boat or being pushed off the
back of his boat that is another option
is not a genuine suicide
anything can happen with plea bargains
because in cases like this after
watching filthy rich and just being
moved by the victims people all over the
world that demanding justice so what
they could do is slap a big sentence on
her now and if is if the fix is in
there's already an understanding that
down the road when it's out of the
public eye this goes to an appeals judge
he gets the right amount of back sheesh
to reduce the sentence and she gets out
without having to serve what was agreed
on what was publicized in the beginning
to satisfy public demand my goodness how
little faith you have in our justice
system
Sean Atwood I can't imagine what led you
here thank you very much indeed as
always for joining us on the mother of
all talk shows that Sean upward with the
pungent point of view on the Maxwell
Epstein affair the polls already running
will Gillen Maxwell face a trial I know
there'll be a plea deal 56% be there'll
be a presidential pardon 17% or see she
will be jailed 27% you can vote right
now on my Twitter feed and already the
votes are flooding in do I have any more
social media I do need some more because
I've still got a few minutes before the
break after the break we'll be talking
of course as always to dr. Ranjit broth
in a week when the coronavirus issue
might be said to have reached a turning
point where the pubs are open where Soho
became a block party which miraculously
attracted no intervention by the police
unlike the block party in Brixton unlike
the block party in the White City the
riot police didn't wait in in Soho which
was literally paved with people Duncan
says Glynn has been charged with a very
limited list of crimes and just from the
90s and not I believe with child rape
sounds like limply bargaining and Jenka
says hopefully with the arrest of
maxwell a number of these corrupt
oligarchs and politicians will be
arrested and taken out of service and
geraldine says when authorities kill
white people nine times out of ten that
man was given a chance to not be killed
black people are arbitrarily being
killed and that my friend is the
difference and citizen journalist ed
George you're on some form tonight big
man thanks sir Georgia I'm trying to
lose my coronavirus weight but thanks
aunt says best way to spend my birthday
evening watching George Galloway very
many happy returns to Europe and Jamie
says I saw this on a sign at a protest
we said black lives matter never said
only black lives matter
we know all lives matter we just need
your help with black lives matter
because black lives are an immediate
danger South Hampton beat Manchester
City won no I demand the stewards
inquiry into that one
Brian says hi George do you have an
opinion on a potential third party in
the usa' called unity 2020 postulated by
Burt Weinstein I don't know who Burt
Weinstein is but his brother Eric
Weinstein has an interesting podcast the
portal on a meeting with Epstein I think
you'd find it very interesting we'll
check that out thanks George says go on
shoot from the hip tell us what you
think of the future of the NHS is this
winter we will feel the effects of the
coronavirus no doubt is the government
taking this virus seriously we have pubs
open but no schools we have the prospect
of mass unemployment and no one seems to
be dealing with a educators George what
is the plan well stay tuned because I'll
be discussing these very things with dr.
Ron G bra let's take a call though from
Simon in Somerset go ahead Simon hi
George hiding goods are nice to hear
from you
Thank You physical and it's time Adam
yeah it was just a quick one just to
address the current moments of time and
I'm really just to put across with
relevance to the the Maxwell and Epstein
kind of revelations
it's just em it's it's quite a
considerable time to address it really
is this time to really give certain
conspiracy theories that have been on
this on the fringe some sort of
validation well fire away give me some
what is this a time to give conspiracy
theories to a certain extent some
validation well there are many many many
many many conspiracy theories but that
doesn't mean everything is a conspiracy
some completely complete cock-up as I
always say Simon I've been close enough
to government unknown enough leader in
leading figures in government including
prime ministers many of them I known
personally up close Harold Wilson James
Callaghan I knew of course John Major
I've sat under many other prime
ministers and I knew Tony Blair and
Gordon Brown only too well and my
experiences that most things are a
cock-up rather than a conspiracy the our
leaders are mr. bean rather than James
Bond but there are plenty of
conspiracies I don't believe for a
moment that Jack Kennedy was killed
only by Lee Harvey Oswald not for a
moment I thank you I don't believe for a
moment that we know everything there is
to know about what happened on 9/11 for
example and I don't believe for a moment
that the the Epstein Maxwell case is
only about sex not for a moment Simon
yes yet I mean yeah exactly on your side
there and that's why I'm an avid
follower and agreement in the majority
of your points I've just done I feel
that there is
quite a certain distancing from certain
callers previously that you know it's
valid with with all those crazy
conspiracies going out there at the
moment that you have to distance
yourself on the platform like yourself
that you have to distance as I always
say Simon if it looks like a duck walks
like a duck and quacks like a duck the
chances are it is a duck
thanks very greatly yeah for a wonderful
call bringing us to the news my goodness
that hour went in quickly the news with
Jimmy lo but stay tuned curiouser on our
curriculum have something to say then
call us now to join the debate on the
mother of all dog shows with George
Galloway tune in every Tuesday to loud
and clear for a regular segment called
false prophets a weekly look at Wall
Street and corporate capitalism where we
talk about the big economic issues of
the week from the point of view of
working people the poor and the u.s.
position in the global economy join us
this Tuesday and every Tuesday with
financial policy analyst Daniel Sankey
right here on radio Sputnik it's time to
double down with Max and Stacy yeah
double down we're talking markets
finance business economics could change
bling just about everything money
related on Sputnik it's called double
down we're asking our dead cats bouncing
or have fundamentals change that's this
week and double down
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
[Music]
radio Sputnik news the rate of the
coronavirus deaths is almost entirely
preventable the UK government's former
chief scientific adviser has said today
Sir David King claimed that a further
27,000 excess deaths are likely between
now and next April under current
approaches to tackling the pandemic and
that this was unacceptable and immoral
Sir David who has been critical of the
easing of lockdown measures said we need
to look at the fastest route out of
covert 19 and the current one is not
right he said it looked as though
Downing streets policy was to maintain
the current level of about 3,000 new
infections per day across England his
comments come as pubs restaurants cafes
and Hair Salons reopened across England
on Saturday amid reports of some people
apparently flouting social distancing
guidelines as new regulations cleared
the path for bars to reopen on what was
widely dubbed as Super Saturday drinkers
packed beer gardens and outdoor areas
this order in some parts of the country
false pubs to close early with police
making arrests after violent clashes
John a patern a tional chairman of the
police Federation for England Wales
criticized the drunken behaviour of some
revelers and said that it was crystal
clear that they would not adhere to the
1 meter plus rule as restrictions were
eased he tweeted finished my late shift
with apt Hampton Police Southampton City
late shift a busy shift we dealt with
anti-social behaviour naked men
possession of Class A drugs happy drunks
angry drunks fights more angry drunks
and was called a fascist Pig by somebody
that we tried to help health secretary
Matt Hancock in contrast said it was
nice to see people Anton about plans to
adequately fund the social care sector
need to be in place within a year the
head of NHS England has said so Simon
Stephens told the BBC the Cobras 19
crisis has shown a very harsh spotlight
on the resilience of the care system
he added I would hope by the time we are
sitting down this time next year on the
73rd birthday of the NHS we have
actually as a country been able to
decisively answer the question of how
we're going to fund
and provide high-quality social care for
my parents generation if you take back
the history coming out of the Second
World War the country at that point was
on austerity we have rationing for bread
and potatoes the founders of NHS did not
use that as a moment to hesitate they
said let one of the legacies of the war
be the creation of the NHS there has
been a world-record rise in coronavirus
cases over a 24-hour period the World
Health Organization has said the new
record is two hundred and twelve
thousand three hundred and twenty-six
with the biggest rise in infections
coming in the u.s. Brazil and India the
previous w-h-o record for new cases was
one hundred and eighty nine thousand and
seventy seven on the 28th of June in the
US there were further 53 thousand two
hundred and thirteen cases reported in
the latest 24-hour period ahead of
Brazil and India across Europe the
figure rose by nineteen thousand six
hundred and ninety-four but as the
United States marked a somber fourth of
July with many people confined to their
homes over coronavirus President Donald
Trump in his speech on the White House
lawn made the astonishing claim that 99%
of coronavirus cases in America are
totally harmless
the president's assertion was without
evidence and was his latest attempt to
minimize the threat of the virus as it
ravages the United States in another
sign of the growing rift between the
West and China Britain is poised to end
the use of far away technology in its 5g
network over security concerns Boris
Johnson is set for a major policy change
after the UK intelligence agency GCHQ is
believed to have reassessed the risks
posed by the Chinese company the Prime
Minister decided in January to allow
quar away to pay a limited role in the
UK's 5g network as he defied security
concerns particularly from the US about
the firm and finally the u.s. rap star
Kanye West has announced in a tweet that
he is running for US president and he's
already won the backing of billionaire
Elon Musk West posted a message to his
twenty nine point four million Twitter
followers suggesting he was entering the
2020 race Tesla chief executive must
bonded to West's tweets saying you have
my full support if Kanye West does run
he won't be stuck for funding apart from
his own money and what musk may offer
him his wife Kim Kardashian last week
saw the stake in her cosmetics company
for 200 million dollars that's the
latest here on Sputnik I'm Jamie Lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio Sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway only on
Sputnik radio will girl in Maxwell face
a trial a know they'll be a plea deal 56
percent be a presidential pardon
seventeen percent see she will be jailed
twenty seven percent of course he and C
are not mutually exclusive but you can
vote now on my Twitter feed at George
gallery have your say on what you think
is going to happen in the ghilane
Maxwell case and I must say the cynicism
of our viewers and listeners is quite
overwhelming faith in the American
injustice system virtually non-existent
anyway it's the 72nd birthday of
Britain's National Health Service which
once upon a time was the jewel in our
crown it was a model which other
countries envied or emulated but as it
reaches 72 years old it's more than
creaking under the weight of the
so-called reforms and the financial
punishment which has taken especially
over these austerity years since 2008 a
long time in anybody's lifetime so who
better to say happy birthday to than dr.
Ranjit bra physician and surgeon and
Motz own medic dr. Ranjit thank you very
much for joining us again we'll come on
to the NHS more generally but you'll
have held on our news bulletin there the
last 24 hours has been a world record
for new coronavirus 19 cases the best
part of a quarter of a million new
infections in 24 hours this isn't going
away is it
if I ever did go away it's coming back
with a vengeance thanks George pleasure
to be with you and we'll say happy
birthday to the NHS and we'll come back
to that question as you say but you're
quite right the NHS is facing really a
kind of perfect storm in terms of the
prevailing systemic conditions and and
the coronavirus certainly has a part to
play in that looking at the world
there's been a million and a half cases
since we last spoke
one week ago George so we're coming up
now to 11 and a half million cases in
the world
with over 500 540 thousand deaths and as
you say every day in the United States
now it's really running rampant out of
control and of course both the US
healthcare system and the Trump
administration as well as the federal
structure of the government without
clear clear guidelines as really who's
to take responsibility for controlling
the pandemic has had a huge impact on
that but more than 55,000 cases every
day for the last three four days is a is
a huge toll but of course then we've
seen increasing impact in the third
world in the BRICS countries Brazil now
has over a million and a half cases
India has recognized that it's got
700,000 cases probably has many more and
and still not accurate really recording
either the number of cases or the number
of deaths so you know as the testing
increases we'll find more and more of
the virus no doubt but equally it's true
to say that the virus is really running
rampant around the entire globe as we
speak George and there's no sign yet of
anything meaningful we can do about it
unless of course one is lucky enough to
get one of the u.s. purchased a
prophylactic switch they have purchased
virtually every single unit in the whole
world has been bought by the United
States the drug companies will charge a
king's ransom for those
there's no guarantee that they'll save
your life in any case and are only
useful if you're already suffering from
it no vaccine this is quite a
frightening time to be squeezing into a
crowded public houses net or filling the
streets of Soho in London with thousands
of people drinking and carousing several
components your question George and ill
all of them quite powerful and valid
this drug REM deseve which is a
nucleotide analog so it's a bit like an
RNA molecule but doesn't assemble
correctly into the genetic structure of
the virus or when it's reassembling it's
been trialed and found to slightly
reduce the duration of illness but not
actually reduced the total mortality of
the disease so it does have probably
some effect though actually the the
randomized controlled trial which led to
its adoption in the United States has
been widely criticized as a paper I've
just read in the BMJ which criticized it
as having a lot of loss to follow up and
not following up all of the patients the
trial being poorly randomized and so
basically poorly conducted and then
drawing a question mark over the results
nevertheless let's assume that it's
correct and it does have some positive
impact it's very telling really the
United States is supremely arrogant I
mean the United States for a long time
has essentially conducted its foreign
policy on the basis that you know the
life of an American it doesn't have
parity with the life of human beings
elsewhere and there's lots of evidence
to attest to that but certainly if you
think that the United States when they
thought there was a vaccine that might
be developed to trump trying to buy up
that company that was a German company
so that and give exclusive use of the
potential vaccine to the United States
and is that a similar thing with with
Gilad who produced this drug this drug
is actually produced in California
Gil and have a limited ability to
produce it you can look at the workings
of capitalism even further and say look
Gil ads share price has gone up 20 to 30
percent within this pandemic precisely
because there were hopes for this drug
and this trial which is probably poorly
conducted
you know has boosted their share price
still further and more than that if you
look at the special laws surrounding and
drugs they were know very keen to get
something called
an orphan drug status for this drug
which essentially is something that I
would normally roll out for a drug for a
very rare disease to ensure that they're
the only people who are allowed to
produce it for seven or eight years and
therefore they're gonna reap back the
full profit now in a pandemic it's
hardly a rare disease it's a worldwide
crisis but they want to limit the profit
to their own company but that would mean
also obviously limiting the treatment
offered to the world so you can see what
motivates you know on the one hand these
massively lucrative enterprises they are
solely concerned with the profit they
can generate from this world crisis
rather than come up with the best way to
tackle the health emergency and that ISM
very typical and we've seen that roll
out in many different ways during this
pregnant but coming back to your the
latter part of your question is this a
good time to be easing lockdown look the
rates are down less there is a
particular case and again you can see
the poor response of the NHS has been
conditioned by those pressures of
privatization that you were talking
about if we look at testing it's been
Deloitte has been in charge of the
testing with the tracing it's been
circled they've been put in charge of
tracing we look at the PPE in the
nightingale hospitals it's been a
coalition of KPMG and an of consortium
rather of KPMG and Deloitte so this
covered 19 laws that have gone through
on the back of the emergence of the
pandemic in the closing down of
Parliament together with anyway the
proclivity of the current government and
previous governments over a long period
of time to increasingly farm out the
responsibilities the health service the
public care albeit under an NH if the
private care albeit are under an NHS
guideline has led to a very disjointed
response where for example in Leicester
the local council was saying they didn't
realize they had that many tests
precisely because actually a large
number of the private tests are in fact
farmed out to another private company
which is the lighthouse labs in
conjunction with Amazon with boots with
with Royal Mail so a whole consortium
private interests are coordinating in a
very loose way which leading to very
poor share
of information and a no single body and
certainly you know it's the system have
kind of a feeling of despair within the
NHS staff that they actually despite
having the expertise to deal with the
pandemic don't have the power to
reorganize the health service and
actually manage the government response
in an inappropriate way George that was
a dazzling description of where we are
where would you prefer we were or prefer
we were heading to this is the birthday
of the NHS let's hope it has many happy
returns but for them to be happy what
needs to happen doctor well George I
don't think that we can trust the
National Health Service in the hands of
governments who over a 40-year period
have made it very clear that their
intention is to privatize the National
Health Service if we if we look back at
the factor administration John redwood
and Oliver let wind published a document
which they would basically was about how
to privatize public services and
particularly focused on the NHS and that
documents called Britain's biggest
enterprise and you know they have an
absolute will and desire to turn over
all of the money very considerable
revenue of the state to private
companies and that would involve
privatizing national services including
the National Health Service amongst
others it's particularly the case with
the National Health Service that it's
kinda persistent pressures to try and
farm it out to different providers the
idea initially was to just get
peripheral services so you know canteen
services or hospital maintenance
services but this is it's been gradually
picking away at the pie until actually a
huge probably the majority of the
National Health Service is privatized
and a whole variety of groups provide
services including you know there
Ankou medical and and incidental
services consortium of private finance
initiatives of banks I take huge chunks
of the NHS capital drug companies
obviously take huge amounts of the
capital so this is the pattern and far
from reversing that trend it was during
this pandemic it's been used to further
push that same agenda so how can we stop
it from happening
well first of all we need to realize
it's happening I still would recommend
all of your views if they've not watched
it to watch Bob Gil's excellent movie
which is available on his channel which
is about the privatisation of the NHS
it's a fantastic film and we'll put the
information up and hope people will
watch that so becoming aware of it they
can get him to come and speak at local
events and and and and see just how this
is being done but increasingly it's
clear to me that there needs to be a
broad public campaign of the use of the
NHS themselves there's no doubt that
there's you know that the clapping for
the NHS is very sincere it's very real
if we go back to the 2012 Olympics when
we put on a huge show really of the
world just how proud we were of the NHS
I know people who are involved in that
you know the Britain has shown how
grateful it is to have this facility of
caring for our sick and our needy when
we most need it but if we don't step up
to defend it realise the ways in which
it's being challenged whittled away eat
in a way I'm afraid to say that we're
going to be left with a system which
looks very much like the u.s. system and
if we look at just how that covered
pandemic is running rampant out of
control in the United States you realize
just how inefficient is it's the most
expensive healthcare in the world and
it's the most inequitable and leaves the
vast number of the population at least
60 million people without any health
care whatsoever in the richest nation on
earth and that is not a model of health
care that we wanted to see Healthcare is
no longer run by the government has been
farmed out to a Kuenn ger a quasi
autonomous non-governmental authority
led by Sir Simon Stevens and that's NHS
England and it's you know NHS England
that we recently found out this week was
actually watching the figures which is
issue
instructions to discharge patients with
with covered from hospital into care
homes to create beds in the NHS and they
became aware and they were watching an
increased rate of infections within care
home was in during this pandemic they
say sixty thousand sixty-six thousand
people have died within care homes they
save twenty thousand of them from
covered but many of those will be
without testing so that numbers could be
far more
so there's gross mismanagement it's not
the management the NHS is not being run
by the clinicians as a constant mantra
every time they introduce a new wave of
privatization that is about clinical
excellence it's about putting conditions
in control but afraid it's a it's a it's
a ghost line funding has been put out to
clinical commissioning groups those
clinical commissioning groups are groups
of GP normally but they don't have the
capacity to plan their increasing input
with groups such as KPMG and the big
four accountancy companies and American
insurance industry particularly United
health is being invited in to oversee
and run that and is being driven very
far down the line of privatization it's
up to the British people really to
prevent that from happening and the
first step to that is an increase in
knowledge and vigilance George I'll be
lucky to see 75 certainly lucky to see
80 unless these things are reversed I
think that's right I think there's that
there is a campaign to try and address
certain issues of it particularly the
NHS sort of the Health and Social Care
Act 2012 which was an act which removed
the responsibility of the Minister of
Health for providing health care to all
Britons and transfer that over to this
quango NHS England it also advanced the
privatization agenda in other ways and I
certainly think we should I think in
line with you your polio running tonight
George demand the end to the
profiteering from the Private Finance
Initiative they've made their money
several times over already it's well
within the ability of a government to
cancel that source of debt and a stroke
and that would be to the great benefit
of every citizen of Britain it's
something that we should all get behind
in
politicians Bravo thank you very much
dr. Ranjit brah Motz medic who has
helped us through this entire emergency
will Gillian Maxwell face your trial a
know there'll be a plea deal B know
there'll be a presidential pardon
C yes she will be jailed you can vote
now on my Twitter feed at George
Galloway let's hear from Vincent in High
Wycombe go ahead Vincent oh hi good how
you doin good nothing Ephram you what
would you like to say yes I'll talk
about the black lives matter and please
fatality yeah I only talk about Amy but
he do you think badly father's hunting
down black people in the street in
America oftentimes yes and in Britain
far more times than we would like to
acknowledge well did the suspect I say
that's true because I got sophistic from
The Wall Street Journal from the
Washington Post and the the amount of
victims Alaskan Americans killed in 2019
white police is 0.1 percent well that's
not 0.1% of what of all homicides like
him aside victims no isn't a better
statistic what proportion of people
killed by a law enforcement what people
of color and I can assure you I can
assure you that that's true and this
thing softens the fighting in a
half-point Malati to be killed by
blackmail and blackmail is to be killed
at least well over a thousand people
last year in America were killed by law
enforcement the great majority of them
were people of color this is a fact no
this is not Church
so in Wilson are you saying
99% of people killed by law enforcement
in the u.s. worldwide were white George
2019 officers shot 1000 for people to
arm two of white dangerous
african-americans about 1/4 those killed
no you said you said less than 1% yes my
best pass of the black homicide victims
it says here in the would speak journal
Journal with oranges 1000 people were
killed by law enforcement last year in
the United States we don't know if they
were armed and dangerous as you appear
to know let's deal with the number and
telling you that the great majority of
that 1000 plus people killed by law
enforcement
we're either black or Latino or
otherwise minority ethnic communities
that's a third that's a fraction a 53%
from the homicide offenders in the US
and the representation
I could see Vincent that you have an
agenda in this conversation actually I'm
proud to say I worked out in the first
25 seconds of what you said the great
majority of people killed by law
enforcement last year and every year in
the United States are people of color
goodbye know if you want to have your
seat on the gallon Maxwell issue will
she stand trial what do you think you
can call in now let me give you the
numbers or two or seven seven nine eight
to 255 or you can call us from the US on
zero zero one seven five seven seven
four four four four eight zero Paul is
in Glasgow on the furlough scheme go
ahead Paul hi jobs high risk for
children
the show Marilla back on so your
question a little boys and the hell
would Scott have been able to afford the
follow scheme had it not been certain UK
government the simple answer to that
would be Scott and Scott would be
entertainment and independent every pay
for the following scheme and exactly the
same way as the UK government ie
taxation vt borrowing possibly constant
easing so quantitative easing of which
currency but you'll not be allowed to
use the pound do you think the Bank of
England is going to allow you to
quantitatively ease its currency school
did you go to Israel if you are
seriously seeing on an international
television and radio program that the
Bank of England would allow independent
Scotland to quantitatively ease its Bank
of England currency then are you just
out for the weekend
no I'm not really sure can you try to
turn him down for a moment and then
we'll bring him back I'm not letting it
go because never have I been lucky
enough to find a Scottish nationalists
demonstrate the absolute economic
illiteracy with which they approach the
issue of independence than you Paul you
are reprise exhibit
you can't count you obviously never went
to school
you are economically imbecilic you came
on this show and claimed
that the British government would allow
an independent Scottish government to
quantitatively ease the British which
you have already left allows you to
print the would never allow the
government of us are you taking
something Paul you're going to need to
slow down because this is not a
conversation this is you with a long
playing record playing up 45rpm this is
route to the point of invasions I'm
asking you
questions and it's this would the US
government allow the government of
Panama to print US dollars yes or no can
may be going to no off you go
because you're not on here to have an
argument you're on here to hysterically
prattle so much so that I'm actually
worried about your blood pressure so I'm
doing you a favor
by allowing you to get back to your
books because you've got a lot to learn
but this demonstrates the absolute
economic numeracy and literacy of the
egypt's running the campaign to break up
Britain and I've got news for you Paul
I'm back and back in Scotland I'm on the
field of battle and what you got away
with with a Scottish Labour Party you
ain't going to get away with with me now
about take a one-minute break radio
snick
[Music]
tune in every Tuesday - loud and clear
for a regular segment called false
prophets a weekly look at Wall Street
and corporate capitalism where we talk
about the big economic issues of the
week from the point of view of working
people the poor and the u.s. position in
the global economy join us this Tuesday
and every Tuesday with financial policy
analyst Daniel Sankey right here on
radio Sputnik want to talk get in touch
with us at radio at Sputnik news calm we
are talking twenty four hours a day
seven days a week you are listening we
give you the most essential out of the
endless information space radio Sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news.com 24 hours a
day seven days a week we give you the
most essential information out there
radio Sputnik telling the untold George
Galloway and the mother of all talk
shells and join us at the College of
knowledge where there are no tuition
fees while most people in the polls seem
to think there'll be a plea deal a few
people think there'll be a presidential
pardon I think that's right because I
can't see what Donald Trump would have
to gain from that 21% only thinks she'll
see the inside of the jail you can vote
on my Twitter feed Dell says on Twitter
this loony Paul is what we have to
listen to on a daily basis up here
George
you wipe the floor with them ha ha ha
well I'll tell you what their backsides
are twitching since I announced in the
last day or two that I'm back in
Scotland and on YouTube qu'il says
deaths are steadily going down in the
USA there are more cases because they're
testing testing more I guess help
prepare professionals can't do maths
signed Donald J Trump John says I can't
understand one word of that guy from
Glasgow and Jay says at work everyone
wears a mask beside me and they even
follow social distancing well someone
brought in the flu and now everyone has
it beside me and no one can answer why
their masks didn't work and Ashley says
Gigi has the best guests and friends and
on Facebook wolf says greedy
corporations should not be running
public health care and Bill says Vincent
have a day off son now my editor Ron
makai gives me this how's this for a
good news story 18 year old Musa Jawara
scored four Bologna in their wins shock
win over Inter Milan today he came to
Italy as a refugee from The Gambia on a
boat alone aged 14 he started playing
for a youth team near Potenza and was
adopted by his coach and he scored his
first goal in Syria today against Inter
Milan how's that Steve is in Washington
I don't know if it's DC
or in the state of Washington we'll find
out Steve go ahead yes it's the state of
law school you're welcome go ahead the
subjects that you've been testing on
today I follow you by the way I didn't
play very much once the Kovach and to
the American elections coming up I
believe there's one person that would
make a very very interesting guest for
you and his name is Brett Weinstein he
is a evolutionary biologist very very
very based in scientific methods and
rather to the to Eric Weinstein who I
believe you have some from Dali yep yes
it was mentioned that on in the show
actually yeah we'll look at that he's
put forward a proposal called unity 2020
where he's offering a third option to
the Democrats and the Republicans and
his proposal had involved Andrew yang
and a retired military man named Raven
Brooke and I really don't enough wings
and this myself can give you but if
Andrew Young is supporting Joe Biden I
understand but you shouldn't look or
listen to why he's putting it forward
the way does he promise I'll I'll check
out I'll check out Steve thanks for that
call I need to press on there's a lot of
people trying to go on ian is in
Hounslow in london on the NHS go ahead
Ian hello George
I just want to follow on from dr. bra
yeah army retired and they chest nurse
myself and I lost my wife 10 years ago
to medical negligence so this is
something quite I'd
go into that because up take too long
and I'll get too upset but what I want
to talk about is the bleeding wound the
past 12 months of 83
listen eighty three point four billion
wasted on medical negligence payouts to
people who've died and suffered
needlessly due to medical bungling and
this is causing a hole in the NHS budget
and also a misery to the people who've
been at the receiving end that's a
staggering number and I'm amazed to hear
that well that's all negligence it's all
to do with these stupid quotas of things
being rushed to meet targets and the
stakes are being made that's what the
root cause of it Wow 83 billion pounds a
year staggering staggering number
Ian thanks will we'll ask dr. bra to
respond to that next week God willing
thanks very much indeed for that called
the Paul is doing great numbers will
will Gillian face a trial
norther be a plea deal overwhelming
support 67% let's hear from Julian in
London on Gillan Maxwell go ahead Julian
our Georgia companies they found the
killer in Manchester good effect it
Manchester on three that is when I saw
the house that she's been hiding in it
reminded me of when they found bin Laden
living in a house in Pakistan it was a
rather nicer than his house it was a 1.1
million dollar cottage in the forest
called yeah
called tucked away well she definitely
was away he was talked to I hope she's
not away well she'd put away I've not
done away with
yes but yeah a candle for a poor Gillan
who even now doesn't know she's going to
commit soon
next week well little do we know what
will happen but of course well we don't
know but bin Laden was killed for the
final time after he got captured so I
think your next post should not be will
your own Maxwell be killed but how many
kinds
will she be killed well I mean III which
are of course the health to survive long
enough to appear in court and to answer
the charges that that have now been
leveled against are both in the initial
indictment but also in the testimony of
dozens of children who claim that she
participated in these sexual assaults on
her I don't have to come to any harm
until she's appeared in court to face
these charges and justice is seen to be
done Julie and many thanks are for that
goal Daniel is in Seattle on the
protests in the United States
go ahead Daniel hello George thank you
as good to see you I love your show
thank you I'm calm I'm calling in
because have we lost Daniel I must read
you while we're trying to get back to
Daniel that my editors just pointed out
that medical negligence paid out in 2019
in England two point three six billion
pounds a year pounds last year in 2019
which is still a staggeringly high
number but of course nothing like as
staggering as the one Ian said in the in
the earlier call Daniels back in Seattle
go ahead Daniel hello Janet hi hello
George yes can you hear me yes very well
well George I'm calling in about
the top protest the black lives matter
protests in Seattle yeah I do want I do
social media for several nonprofit
organizations and I had the unfortunate
experience the other night being online
and watching this car drives through the
protesters in real time yeah no women
will see this Lynn Georgia yes one two I
guess and I'd build my goodness I'm
sorry it's it summer Taylor was your
name and she was a 24 year old woman
from see actually I think she verified
his binary but but she died Saturday
night in our dodgy Medical Center and
the other woman her name is a das alone
he's 32 years old from Portland she she
is in serious condition since done the
hospital ayah and god I hope she makes
it through I mean it's been a punch and
that's in the gut yeah did they
immediately arrest the driver who
deliberately mode these women done yes
they did they didn't arrest him he did
sort of try to make a getaway
you know the whole thing doesn't make a
hell of a lot of sense because the
freeway was closed down people have to
understand that the protesters every
night went on the freeway and the police
the State Patrol rather in this case and
the Department of Transportation said
okay we'll close the freeway down for
safety and they would block off the
entrances to the freeway and put a
barricade across across the freeway this
man access the freeway by going the
wrong way on a ramp because he wanted to
get on the highway and mow you know go
he must have been going I don't know if
you've seen that the film
how does know it I recommend that you
don't look at it and show up strong
stomach but but we both of these two
young girls down they were actually
dancing
dancing in the freeway and this is the
cops knew this the cops didn't you know
this is how this is Seattle where it's a
revolutionary place and also I am the
final thing that's age which is there's
been a big I think misinterpretation or
on propaganda about shop about the
autonomous zone they started here and
don't no longer exist they cleared it
several days ago but but it's been a
focal point by the by Trump and you know
basically saying a bunch of BS about
what's going on there it's it's young
kids they're experimenting they're a lot
of new newly political its system pretty
much you know a wonderful place a lot of
you know it's a Seattle type of place
well I've spoken there more than once
thanks Daniel father and we must pray
that the second of the two victims
survives this horrific deliberate
attempt to model her Brian is in Glasgow
but wants to talk about Joe Biden go
ahead Brian thank you she was gonna say
so he George yes George something he
didn't know your name he couldn't be
coming to Scotland I was hoping that
therefore I could ask you a question a
very yeah go ahead
okay you for that go ahead would you
intend to do a very family law I'm the
children are currently reviewing and I
very mysterious we haven't see because
of the shutdown or things like ants
courting floral Commission they've been
under the cover a cool with nineteen but
they're certainly I she's in the garden
and compatibility the Garden estates of
unmarried fathers and their children or
unmarried follows the majority it
doesn't set compatible with that echr
rates is incomparable what potential
rates and almost eighty principles in
law in 2006 family law was caught or not
which my case was said who to influence
and and is quoted a that I did not
address this
the issues in my case which was observed
from my daughter's a life certificate
and that's the only conditionality now
you may enjoy as of 2006 something
course there couple of awards that we
have to your children and it doesn't
look like nature it doesn't reflect ECHR
doesn't reflect the key things in sports
law and any Parliament eating I should
be able to question in their ability to
wage asleep well look Brian I'm not up
to commenting in detail on the your case
or the only act itself I should tell you
I'm not coming there to be a
parliamentarian so I'll not be able to
pass that I'm coming back into Scottish
politics for one purpose only and that
is to try and defeat the the perpetual
hamster wheel politics in which a
country is currently locked have only
one purpose in Scottish politics and
that is to help and try to unite others
to defeat the SNP so that real politics
in Scotland can begin again like the
issue that you have raised like issues
of Education of health of the economy of
transport or policing of all the things
that normal people argue about real
politics as long as Scotland is locked
locked down into a perpetual
constitutional mania over whether or not
there's going to be another referendum
on whether or not Scotland is going to
be independent or not we have to get
away from that that's my purpose I've
got no other purpose Brian just
absolutely only seen him sheet where he
fantastic and can I see that's my whole
point with them if you actually were
gone I can send you all I can't send you
later of some of that I've been
corresponding with to Scotland to the
extent nice things yeah it doesn't get
elected
duty and the way they are greeting us a
a poetic imaginations which as you see
are almost distraction points and their
inability to be effective and anything
with the gas was a rematch
yeah well I'm almost a cultural nice yes
a French exactly what Brian for example
a a significant number of vigilantes
gathered at the border yesterday in
their space suits the Chernobyl suits
screaming English people to get the F
out of Scotland and the police were
standing there and did nothing about it
while if they had been shouting at black
people if they'd be shouting at Jewish
people they've been shouting at Catholic
people something would have had to be
done it is surely at least a public
order offence yet to be trying to be
singling out English people at the
border coming across all the while by
the way when aeroplanes are landing in
Edinburgh and Glasgow with thousands of
falling not British foreign visitors to
spend money in Scotland without even so
much as the temperature being taken what
kind of police force allowed that
yesterday stood by while all happened in
all its ugliness George George I have a
sticky crate clear today a police call
and an email and I can send you a copy
there and police Scotland doing start
having I worked even privately let's say
the members of parliament I don't know
behavior as I interact with them I will
start reporting model management I will
pray in some way to prove that I was
late you just said yeah there was
there's no at least to say she sent he
caused entry an alarm
not knocking people notification at
least jotting down what have I been
there
with my children in the car yeah and a
guy in a jar noble suit is screaming get
the F out of Scotland in my car window
I can't wait wait back from the memory
and all exactly Brian thank you very
much indeed I need to press on alas
there's bill in Scotland on on ghilane
go ahead bill no it's not there yet
let's go therefore to Joshua in London
are you right George
goodnight go ahead quickly yeah I was
gonna just ask about well you know the
International state goat strikes again
that being Russia of yes whipping boys
although it might be China next week you
never know I think it's probably a
combination of both access access of
like you know blame blameworthiness
reprehensibility I think is the work
anyway yeah I'm just gonna while I do
believe he can easily believe the
Russian oligarchs donated to the
conservative party's campaign in 2019
there would appear to have done so
big-time yeah
no I acknowledge that he can't there's
no point denying it but I mean the idea
that they would have that leave
referendum campaign when it would play
right into the hands of the remains side
by saying you know but by tainting the
new campaign as a foreign agent when it
was supposed to be a patriotic
nationalistic movement I know for us it
wasn't we didn't vote necessary for
those same reasons as a lot of uses but
it would be self-defeating in practice
for Russia to meddle in that to this
much that lead campaign because it was
just discourage people from voting to
leave well look it's also the idea that
the voters in Sunderland
were waiting for a communique from
Vladimir Putin in the Kremlin to tell
them that membership of the EU was not a
good thing for them hadn't worked out
very well for them is utterly absurd and
of course they keep talking
Russians oligarchs are living in London
from Russia to get away from the Kremlin
to get away from President Putin the
living here in London because they've
got something to run away from Russia
for at the idea of that because the
Russian oligarch gives money to Boris
Johnson's election campaign that this is
somehow the Russians it's the opposite
of the truth
these are Russians that Putin hates and
who hate Putin gotta go
Joshua bill is in Scotland probably the
last call bill go ahead a Georgian
calling just to mention of it max well
yes and it's quite clear that she will
do a deal just as soon as her father
couldn't do the backstroke she will you
never got a chance to do the deal did he
no no he was too busy uh scuba diving
yeah what's your take on that bill that
was quite heavily involved in at the
time and the fact that he disappeared
off the book as a lot of people think he
committed suicide but I knew Robert
Maxwell quite well and he struck me as
the sort of man that would that would
commit suicide I I remember your being
involved at a time and and and yes you
know I knew also have only through the
papers like date one is that he he
didn't fall like he didn't jump
overboard it was he pushed
I don't know well either jumped or he
fell or he was pushed
I think the the jury's out still on
which of these three options actually
happened bill but you reckon that
ghilane will will sing will she sing on
Prince Andrew or she'll thing I like
about but where it goes from there I
don't know she was saying there's no
doubt about that to save her at his
facing she's facing that if
by 40 years in sing-sing never mind
reading thanks for the call I've gotta
clear the line because there's a legend
on the line and you know the rules the
deck has to be cleared because it's
Norma in Bristol go ahead my lovely
Norma hello is not relevant to the
programme which they've been listening
to birds this is my sort for the day on
television i watch this program about
the philosopher Socrates the greatest
yes and it is about two and a half
centuries ago and he search for the
truth now there were questions like what
makes us truly happy and it might sound
trite but he said finding our soul and
then there's another question how to be
human and he always said always search
know just what you do and that's what I
do a lot of people just research don't
we and that is so important nowadays how
however it was hardly executed with M
lock poison and because he won't popular
with his so-called Greek democracy but I
I have got a great regard for Socrates
me too and his name liveth forever more
so the people are poisoned them are long
forgotten the the most important
Socratic principle that I support Norma
is that the richest among us
should be no more than three times
richer than the poorest among us and
imagine what a transformative thing that
would be if the poorest person in the
country was was if the richest was not
more than three times richer than the
poorest person in the country if the
first person in the line could always
see the first the last person in the
line and the last person in the line
could always see the first person in the
line that kind of society would be a
much happier society than the one we've
got now
Norma I'm sure you agree with me on that
Thank You Norma as always for bringing
the show to I hope a successful
conclusion it's been marvelous for me I
hope it was for you and if it was come
back next week at the same time same
place and bring another listener or
viewer with you
[Music]